[Music]
hello and welcome to Paris the sight of
the first leg of the 2017 Grand chest
tour last year's winner hi CaRu Nakamura
will'll see if he can pull off a repeat
but he'll be chased by 2016 Grand chess
tour winner Wesley so as well as a host
of old and new Rivals including one
Magnus Carlson let's go to the studio
with yovanka Yasser and
Christian wow hello hello good morning
from the studio here in St Louis test
club I'm International marang gas and
it's absolute great pleasure to be here
with grand s Yi welcome to St Louis it's
great pleasure to be here yes well the
third Grand chest St is set to get off
to an exciting start in Paris we'll have
10 of the finest chess mines battling
out in Rapid and blessed format isn't
that exciting yes and here's a list of
the participants headed by Magnus
Carlson the world champion and if you're
looking at that rating it's the
universal rating system which is
brainchild of Gary Kasparov which
combines all the disciplines of Chess
classical rapid and Blitz into one
rating system and there it is wow what
an allar lineup well we have some
surprising rankings there we have former
world champion wrestling topof on number
nine it's incredible and you think about
what vesselin has done in the world of
Chess Dynamic style former World Chess
Talent Serge Kina and number eight yes
yes and so moving on to our schedule
well we could well we see we're in for a
thrilling 5day chest chess Fest and uh
the rapid chess would be covered over 3
days it's a nine round robin and it has
a rather interesting time control of 25
minutes plus a 10-second delay this is
not an increment it's a delay right you
can never get additional time and in the
Blitz something very similar a 5 minutes
per player at start but a 3se second
delay and that's much slower than the
normal Blitz we'll see how the players
adjust themselves but we have three days
of Rapid to look forward to yes yes and
of course you mustn't forget that the
rapid point at occasion will be two
points for the win as meanwhile in the
blitz it will be just one point per
game so uh let's take a look at the
pairings for round one w we have some
intriguing matchups look at the first
board the car in Nakamura versus Shaq
mamadov yes and the challenge is Sergey
kakin versus former world champion
vessel in to BL All-American match Fabby
Wesley all French matchup at TN versus
NBL of course the clash of the Styles
Alex gisi versus magmus Carlson that is
one to watch absolutely that's the game
I want to pay attention
to okay let's let's check a look take a
look at the playing Hall out and we see
all the players getting ready
a very very different staging from Paris
last year here the players are playing
in a TV studio uh isolated uh no live
audience and uh before we came on on air
we were discussing whether or not you
prefer a live audience I do you're yeah
I'm kind of on the f I think it'll be
relaxing it'll be easier for the players
to start off in this very safe reaction
and uh we are very lucky to be joined in
the studio by grandm and our analyst
Christian Killa Christian what are you
looking forward to thanks guys I'm
extremely excited about the beginning of
the 2017 Grand chest tour for various
reasons first and foremost we have
Magnus Carson who's losing his dominance
in the classical time control in the
rapid and Blitz he's still the top dog
so I'm expecting all the other guys to
try to take that Crown away from him
he's still the highest rated Blitz flare
on the planet with an rating of over
2900 this is going to be an explosive
week blink and you'll miss all the
action back to you guys thank you uh
Christian and I tell you Magnus In
classical chess has been underperforming
but his standards are so high yes but in
Rapid he's been unbelievable absolutely
unbelievable in
Stanga and let's go to Maurice Ashley in
Paris Maurice bring us the inside info
what's the atmosphere like well it has
been hot hot hot here in Paris the
temperature has been in the high 90s but
we expect some sizzling action on the
chess board here as well we are in the
spectacular Studio here for Canal plus
television this is being broadcast live
on French TV this that's how much of a
big deal this tournament is and it
should be we have all the best players
in the world certainly we have last
year's wi Hikaru Nakamura who took the
tournament by storm we also have the
grand chest Tor champion from 2016
Wesley so who had a great performance as
well last year at the very beginning and
of course as you guys mentioned Magnus
Carlson who has made no bones about it
he wants to put his foot on everybody's
neck to reestablish his dominance as the
best player in the world and oh yeah the
best rapid and Blitz player in the world
as well so it'll be an exciting
tournament we will be bringing you the
action live here from Paris
thank you Maurice and by the way we do
have in our field the world champion for
Rapid yes that is Sergey I believe yes
and then when in Blitz wasn't it grishuk
the world Blitz Champion yeah he was a
previous oh he was the
pr
Berlin I think Sergey is the Blitz World
Champion world champion iuk ivanchuk is
rapid yes a very popular in it by the
way this is a great tournament but yeah
every impressive tournament has an
impressive price fond you know so uh the
every Blitz Blitz and Rapid event in the
grand Chester has a total price fund of
$150,000 not bad and uh first place runs
away with
$375,000 not bad again right very tasty
and second place is $25,000 and third
20,000 very very nice
for the uh first leg and last year's
Grand chest winner Wesley so look what
he took home out of the total 1.1
million he got the Lion Share got
$295,000 huh Bravo taking that one into
your account exactly so it was 1.1
million in total price fund last year
this year it's up to how much it's 1.2
million so a slight increase yes because
of the
fifth St Louis Blitz
yes that's right that will follow of
course the sinkfield cup but after this
first leg the players will be moving on
to Len there'll be just a few days in
between as the players will go from P
see Wesley fiddling around with a
interesting bag yeah Magnus waiting and
the new and the new glass Look
new he's lost he's lost the hair he's
lost the Wild Hair yeah wasn't a fan of
that one yeah I must say cuts a dashing
figure doesn't he definitely yeah our
world champion we're all very proud
Christian you're looking at the players
who are your picks as we're getting
ready for the first round to go underway
top three well yaser this might upset
you uh I have Magnus Carlson there's
absolutely no chess discussion without
uh without a top dog uh I have shakri
arm medarov very very strong rapid
player very strong Blitz player he's on
a role he just taste uh that 2800 level
fine wine and then I have 2015 if I'm
not mistaken Blitz World Champion
Alexander Guk so unfortunately this year
no Americans for me yo wow and yourself
I'm going to agree with him on Magnus I
think you know you have to include
Magnus but I'm going to include an
American I'm going to go for Hikari I
mean he plays such awesome blitz and I
know he is the bullet King you can't
defending Paris Champion as well yes and
uh of course yeah he did very well last
year and I'm going to throw in a wild
card uh I'm gonna put in Alex GIS
grischek you know he's such a strong
yeah such a strong Blitz player well I
can see the favorites really mix I have
to go with Magnus I have to go with
Wesley I've just never seen such
consistency for a non world champion
he's just been wonderful when did he
have a bad result Stang Blitz yeah yeah
the blitz uh but I'm going to choose a
little bit of a Dark Horse with uh Mami
as well M I think he's been on a tear
and he's lit up the Chess World what he
did in Shamir in aeran and then in the
Russian Team Championship he's hot hot
hot and just as Christian said the 2800
wine he's tasted that for the first
and it tastes good and he's a wild card
as well so super
motivated and Maurice you got a weigh in
with your top
picks well it obviously is incredibly
difficult to choose although the easy
one is clearly Magnus Carlson coming off
such an horrific event in Norway he is
absolutely hungry to prove that he is
indeed the best chess player in the
world and he just wants revenge you
could see it when I was interviewing him
just yesterday also I'm going to go with
Hikaru Nakamura as well because he
always seems to land on his feet in
these types of events he was the winner
last year so he's definitely coming in
the top three as far as I'm concerned
but my Outsider believe it or not is
going to be another American Fabiano
caruana I had uh been H I've been having
lunch and dinner with him uh so far he's
not happy with the way he's been
performing here uh in the last few
months or so so he is hungry as well so
I have a little inside info on him I
think that he's going to surprise us all
and rise to the challenge wow thank you
a very very surprising yes we all do
have favorites and and well for this uh
what what a way to kick off with this
Alexander grishuk uh Magnus Carlson key
matchup and I was looking at uh the body
uh of um Magnus there and he did seem
focused confident this body language you
could you saw it in the world
championship he's focused he wants this
and uh he's ready he's ready to pounce
yeah feel same goes for gik though I
can't wait for the starter pistol I I
suppose they're going to be having some
uh introductory comments shortly and
Christian you had mentioned that
although Magnus has not been performing
in the classical when it comes to the
Blitz and Rapid he just plays on
Instinct and intuition intuition
intuition for sure when when when you
have longtime controls is much easier to
delve deep into calculation when you
have shorttime controls you have to play
uh based on your intuition and that's
where Magnus has the edge for sure in
the past decade decade I would say he
has that edge and uh he he doesn't seem
to be losing it so I'm seeing him uh as
as uh an angry
Magnus angry Magnus going for the kill
do you well unusually in Stang he uh he
showed that he was lacking in confidence
do you think that this lack of
confidence will perhaps show him well I
actually was stunned by the interview
that he did gave uh in stabinger where
he mentioned just as you said that he
didn't think when am I going to win
again I I was absolutely this is not the
Magnus that we come FL because this is
you know there's a little Maxim in chess
ELO equals ELO ego you know the higher
the ego the higher the ELO so uh
yeah what's gonna happen well I really
felt that during the World Championship
you know he was staring into the abyss
he was a point behind with just a few
games to play and really um Sergey s you
know help saved him uh because he didn't
have that
uh Killer Instinct that he's so noted
for there's a lot of changes in his life
a lot of Chang there's a lot of changes
you know the emotions intensify the
longer you are at the top you know the
the harder the fall will be so he's
feeling that he's internalizing that but
uh he had his drop right now I think
he's going to go back uh in the
classical time control to like 2850 and
uh and above so I I'm I'm seeing Magnus
as stabilizing there and now going for
another
push yes yeah what's all the waight
about uh I mean we may have to go to
Maurice to get some insight as to
oh have a legend we have a chess Legend
Gary Kasparov here we go Gary Kasparov
legendary all French all French matchup
yes and it looks like Canal BL is uh
interviewing Gary what would he say do
you think he's just delighted to be here
I mean for Gary uh his whole career he
has been pursuing commercial
sponsorships he really wants to see
chess elevated to a major sport and it's
always been difficult to organize a tour
and he's seeing
it happen for the third year now he's
asking move G4 one
G4 I don't think so okay no ready here
we go of course of course keep it solid
in the battle of the Frenchman yes yes
the all French matchup yeah and that was
Gary casparo and play seems to be
underway we'll we'll be starting shortly
and there we have the opening moves
we'll start with uh Sergey pardon me
grishuk and Magnus because that's the
game and there's the All-American
matchup G3 G and Maurice so Maurice tell
us a little bit about this game
well actually I wanted to just discuss
what's happening here what's so
intriguing we're going to get camera
shots we have to get of the amazing
studio that Canal plus has put together
you see the players sitting there
playing but actually you have a
commentators like we are and I think
it's five of them actually on staff
right now and they're calling the action
it's just a spectacular Studio I got to
tell you wherever Rex singfield is he's
got to build one of them for us in St
Louis because that is putting us to
shame right now in Paris just a
beautiful beautiful studio just so that
the audience all over France can watch
and see just how exciting this chess
action is wow nice thank you Maurice uh
boy uh a lot of the players are going
very very quickly but the game that I
was featuring was going very slowly we
have something very unusual going on in
the game uh it's not according to the
prayer book that we all sing from atan
versus MV what is that uh Christian uh I
actually yes thank you I actually played
the this variation quite recently in the
St Louis Invitational uh this is some
sort of London system G6 and now Knight
C3 this is a very enterprising move uh
you're forcing black to to to take a
decision he can either play D5 but then
what I expect he had in mind is E3 and
then an expansion with with the H Pawn
this is very very r revolutionary right
now so after Bishop G7 we're entering
we're entering completely different
territory because white can grab the
center with E4 after D5 interesting move
E5 Knight E4 Knight to A4 Knight wow
yeah You' expect honly I do not
understand this move Knights on the rim
usually are not uh the best pieces but I
see what he's trying to do I think he's
trying to go F3 and endanger this Knight
on e4 where are you going to put your
knight trapped right so black play C5 C3
C takes D4 he's probably going to take
with a c with a c pawn and well actually
C pawn queen A5 Queen A5 check this
might be a problem Knight C3 Knight
takes C3 and maybe Queen D yes this
could be an idea then we take back on C3
with the pawn and then again H4 H5
expansion on the king side not losing
material but how about the
uncompromising F2 F3 in what position uh
yes you want be you mentioned the
night's trap well you yeah let's I maybe
G5 G5 perhaps oo G5 Bishop C exposive
action huh yes this is this is Uncharted
Territory uh nobody knows what's
happening maybe aten has an idea maybe
he prepared this at home he must have
done play play Knight A4 you don't you
don't do that unprepared this is a good
rapid variation in my opinion wow you're
asking a lot of questions a lot of
questions indeed as the first round gets
underway I'm looking at the game between
Hikaru and Shaq it looks like a
bononi uh with an early E2 E3 let's see
how that all got started okay so we have
a groom Fel Kings Indian start with E3
and Bishop E2 this is a bit restrained
by hearu C5 D5 so transposing into a
Boni where the pawn E3
yeah white doesn't care I think white
doesn't care that as long as he gets the
he says the bonon structure is so good
white I don't care if I'm going to lose
well yeah but I just feel that black uh
should be pleased himself because he
he's got an easy game easy development
but you have white has the space if you
like your space and indeed that pawn on
D5 and I do like the space I I also like
my
space I respect your space and let's
just go to the G All-American matchup
something similar to ettien oh and okay
so it's a grunfeld with the early Knight
E4 Queen
B3 and castles and the players have
played very quickly indeed E2 E4 Knight
C6
E5 whoa okay B so B6 so the bishop on C8
of course needs a and get get a diagonal
for himself and also control the C I
mean the C porn C3 Pawn is a very
natural targeta try to control its
advance and Wesley did precisely that
Rook C8 uh preparing to Bear Down
against the pawn on C3 but again we like
space Fabi Fabby dropped back with Queen
D1 and again some very unusual openings
and I
must I'm pleased but we have a special
guest a special guest in Paris yes
Maurice Maurice tell us all about him
oh well we have Grandmaster Roman Edward
from France himself French GM who will
not just be a guest he'll be a full-time
partner in crime as he is looking at all
the niceties all the interesting Games
first of all ROM welcome to the show
what is it like having a tournament like
this right here in your home country
with all these Big Time Players well I'm
really happy to well I'm really happy
that it takes place and I'm very happy
to be able to follow it
closely um well I mean there are not so
many top tournaments in France and
thanks to because some new persons like
J are coming and some new tournaments
are uh being created and uh well I'm
very very happy about it I hope one day
I can play in them but it's already a
big honor to to talk about to commentate
on them absolutely and you have your
Frenchman here Ian brro and Maxim Vash
gra I'm sure you've played them a few
times already what can you tell us about
the Rivalry between these two players
well look they're extremely big friends
they work together fulltime so I I
really didn't know what to expect uh in
the opening well in in the bled game
they can play anything but in the rapid
game uh of course you cannot play you
cannot play anything you have to still
play something decent um so you're
saying they're friends it's hard to yeah
they're big friends they play together
so I didn't know would the would Ian
just play very solid with white what
would happen I didn't know and well it
turns out he's not exactly playing solid
he went for this bishop f4 on a second
move and now they reached some extreme
critical position uh when Maxim hasn't
spent a single second sinking and well
aan is now singing for quite some
minutes and this is perhaps not such a
good news for him because here well it
looks like CD4 should be the normal move
but then well at any moment black can
play Queen A5 check so for example
castle and if white wouldn't try to
capture the Knight then there would be
Queen A5 check and black black would be
excellent so well computer here says
that uh move f should be played and then
it it looks like black should play G5
and now white should play Bishop C1 and
Knight C coming some some crazy computer
line which very probably Maxim is aware
of Maxim is definitely aware of this
line you know how he he has that big
computer at home exactly so well this is
not a very good start for aan because
he's probably not feeling very
comfortable in the game already and he's
the lowest rated player in the field as
well so he must feel himself quite
nervous yeah well I mean he also takes
it fun you know okay just wants to play
good games and uh well if he manages to
do something good then he will be
extremely happy um but of course it
would be a pity for him to lose the
first game with white uh just in the
opening so let's hope for him that uh
he's going to find all these computer
moves because probably this position is
not that clear um well we'll we'll take
a look at it we'll throw it back to the
studio but we'll keep our insights here
with grandmas ran Edward as the all
French matchup continues live on French
television at that that was just an
accident of the drawing but it's what
the French people get to see two of
their countrymen battle it out right
away in round one here from Paris thank
you Maurice Explosive Start to this
round one interesting information that
the two actually worked together I
wasn't aware of that yeah in fact uh
during the Baku Olympiad I saw that the
French team really are very very
friendly with one another they hung out
together they ate together that did a
lot of analysis played a lot of cards in
the evening they have a special French
card game uh that they all seem to enjoy
very much now in the game between
grishuk and Magnus that I thought we
would feature as our first game of the
round kind of future uh it was an
exchange SLO but then came a very uh
surprising
move everybody and his brother plays
Knight C3 and Knight F3 here uh Gish
hook ESS Bishop G5 I I mean I've played
the white side and I don't recall ever
considering this move ever and Magnus
just developed Knight C6 and the
question what is your Bishop doing Bop
doing these are the type of moves that
make Guk such an exciting player uh you
play Bishop G5 he was trying to entice
Magnus to play
G6 but then he's uh he's not going to go
into the type of types of positions he
he enjoys after Knight C3 Bishop G7
let's say something like E3 Knight F6 um
this bishop on G7 is not feeling very
comfortable because of this Pawn chain
uh blocking him so Magnus decided to go
Knight C6 Knight C3 Knight F6 challenge
he's not afraid of challenges m is
definitely not afraid of challenges so
Bishop takes F6 he got the bishop pair
the structure is a little bit damaged
but uh I'm pretty sure the world
champion is enjoying the bishop a and
uh in the final position I I I prefer
black really I like the long-term
chances of black with a bishop pair
really I'm shocked by your by you both
okay so let's take a look so after this
move Rook C1 came Bishop
F5 uh Bishop coming to
D3 uh attacking uh trying to take away
the bishop Bishop dropped back and you
know I'm an old Pond grubber okay and I
just wanted to make sure that Bishop
takes G6 H takes G6 was not in the
position because earlier in the game
Magnus had played A7 A6 and this is a
well-known trap but it didn't stop me
from falling for it three or four times
before I understood yes Queen takes B7
is not possible because well sadly you
get your queen trapped by a knight sh
that pawn on A6 covers the B5 no so we
can't um take advantage but
I also like the damag pawn structure
that white has created in Black's Camp
these doubled F pawns so here's a
challenge
H4 okay so what are you g to do you're G
to go E6 you don't want to play H5 no
I'm not going to play H5 then I'll take
on G6 and you'll be compromised I think
I'm going to go Bishop G7 Bishop G7 so
having said a one must say B H5 Bishop
takes D3 Queen takes D3
and um obviously I'm not going to
Castle I think that would be well
question where are you going to put the
king you're not going to go king queen
side maybe I can live happily in the
center okay so we'll start with E6 so
I'm going to disturb you and force your
Bishop back and we'll go on like this
but the pawn on H6 is is a disturbance
but it's also a weakness in that it's a
double edged it's double edged but the
problem is Rook on h8 going to G6 is not
scary I'll have a knight F4 to chase you
back I will start with Rook G8 I think
that's that's a promen h Queen takes H7
yes a coordinator I was thinking F5 yes
F5 F5 and maybe I'm not so scared of
your
night all right I'll do
G36 D Queen F6 oh grab we really in
grabbing territory here hey you guys I'm
the one who's the pond grabber the
family I know Joy likes to take
pawns I land quickly don't yes yes we're
pull side yesterday every so you're
playing for long-term initiative y yeah
just
asking well what if I go Bishop G5 to
try to play H5 H4 right very good
question and I still want to keep
control over the F4 very important so
yeah I think uh I think the black has
been quite good in terms of equalizing
the early initiative there's still some
Rook pressure there's a lot of pressure
H5 I'll jump in with my
knight or I could have even play Knight
B6 that's a weird move but okay I like
before Rook H5 instead of Knight
A4 uh sorry uh in this moment in this
position Rook H5 we'll start with this
just to prevent H5 you mean cuz now if I
if you play H6 I go F4 your Bishop
[Music]
that's nasty that is a
nasty oh there is Queen G6 Queen G6 Rook
H1 and then I move my Bishop back and I
go crisis averted right and here okay
there's some pressure for the definitely
pressure but okay I do like uh gish's uh
Bishop G5 takes F6 because it definitely
imbalances the position and H4 H5 while
enterprising by no means necessary
white can also just comfortably just say
you're not because you're not really
going to play E5 this Pawn on D5
unprotected I think my plan would just
be to play very solid solidly and react
you know react to whatever white does
and then
okay by the way the game clock Magnus a
little bit behind sorry Christian uh I
just wanted to ask you about uh the game
between Carana and Wesley the Battle of
The Americans it's a very interesting
position with both sides attacking uh on
their dominant side so white played A4
Knight A5 attacking the pawn on on on C3
and now a very nice move Rook to E3 what
is this rooking Rook doing on E3
defending the C3 Pawn but also preparing
after H4 G4 Rook can swing on on H3 H5
uh mating attack is coming queen D7 H4
Knight C4 Knight takes C4 I don't know
about this Knight C4 why would you want
to exchange that Knight this Knight
doesn't see doesn't seem very appealing
to me uh you want to redirect it via F1
H2 perhaps G4 and try to put some
pressure on the king side but if you do
that I get the C4 Square for my KN
so I would have kept my knight on A5
instead Wesley played Knight C4 Knight
takes C4 Bishop takes C4 H5 A5 to be
honest I prefer White's position he
seems to have a free attack and black
doesn't have any initiative on the queen
side what do you think I I I like it for
white as well because it's pushing pawns
and I love
to the H5 you know G yeah no I I do like
the versatility of this move Rook E3
because of what you said this lateral H5
G4 Rook H3 uh attempts
uh that you have mentioned and as you
say it's a free attack it's not 100 %
completely free because of this move A5
what black is trying to do is one day
play oops just a second one day play B5
Force the trade Queen takes B5 and then
what Wesley says is well I'll have a
passer if you don't Checkmate me uh the
passer could be strong well before the
end game comes the middle game middle
yes I play the normal moves go G4
exactly just simply G4 and I'm with you
on this uh yeah I mean I I like uh what
white has concocted here and this Rook
as it swings across this bishop will
obviously one day plant itself on F6 and
there's going to be some dark Square
issues that Wesley's got to deal with it
may turn out that Wesley's going to have
to play F6 F5 F7 F6 or F7
F5 just to deal with this pressure guys
you would be surprised what the computer
is is offering in this position he wants
to play Bishop H6 and actually exchange
the dark Square Bishop very unnatural
very unal Rook H3 human I think Bishop
takes E1 I mean do you really want to
bring my queen to H6 no no no no this
this looks very bad for black and um the
computer still likes uh still likes
white not as much uh it's only like a
half a pawn or like less than that but
uh from from a human perspective this
this we would be terrified really bad
yeah and I'd be slapping the hands of my
students for trading off their dark
Bishop he has played B5 uh I was going
to suggest B5 with this idea because
there are some ideas of Queen takes B5
and then perhaps at the right time I
could maybe defend with a bishop D3 to
when I'm when you get too carried away
with your and I'll probably get yeah
I'll probably get carried away but we
have Mor Paris
Maurice and we definitely have to pay
attention to this all French matchup
because Maxim Vash lra one of the best
players in the world and certainly
someone who could be a favorite to win
this event has been blitzing out his
moves against his Frenchman and good
friend eten bak and in this position
Knight C3 the sacrifice bc3 and queen A5
all kinds of threats happening in the
position but after Queen D4 Knight C6
Queen dropping back to D1 to defend the
Knight Knight takes on E5 and now Bishop
D2 because this C3 Pawn needs to be
shorted up and a strange move Knight to
C4 offering an exchange for white this
one we are not sure about he blitzed it
though I mean he played it instantly in
this position the engines are just
giving castles why give this bishop any
work to do at all let white make some
move to lose a Tempe maybe for example
if white were to play Bishop after
castles if I were to play Bishop E2
right now you could play Knight C4 and
make him Trade It not that that's
necessarily the best move but let the
bishop at least lose a Tempe while
you're castling that makes sense instead
in this position he played Knight C4
immediately and back Crow did not need a
second look at this memo he took this
off the board immediately takes takes
Knight to E2 and now the position with
castles is on the board the engines are
giving white a gigantic edge here not a
whole piece uh that you would count as
you realize he's a piece up for what
looks like two pawns but still an edge
for white the engines have stabilized
the position as far as white is
concerned are we still in Maxim's
preparation well we know he's a beast
when it comes to using his engines and
preparing deeply so we'll see whether or
not he has any surprises as the
Frenchman go at it in front of all of
Paris thank you Maurice and I couldn't
agree with Maurice Moore I mean why play
knight5 to C4 when the bishop hasn't
moved let it make it gives your opponent
an Easy Choice as well you
what can you do you just have toow but
it is an interesting decision because
the Knight on a A4 I was about to say it
doesn't have a role uh for the two pawns
it it's still it's going to it's going
to take it a couple of moves to get back
into
civilization that's a nice maneuver to
perhaps to E3 and right F2 so we're
going to take some Tempe but we do get a
we do get a tempo right away with Knight
B2 and white black is probably going to
go either Bishop E6 or let's just toss
out Bishop E6 for a sec and queen
D1 uh to C1 to get off this pin uh big
advantage to pawns some awkwardness is
with the King how do you feel about
White's compensation here Christian um I
believe Knight C4 was a horrendous
misjudgment from uh from Vash year for
sure um this type of sacrifices are all
based on one thing and that is
initiative if you don't manage to keep
the initiative going then you're not
going to get anything out of it um we're
going to exchange some pieces we're
going to go into an end game and white
is just going to have a piece up so this
Knight C4 why are you helping me to
Castle why are you helping me to bring
my Bishop out um big big misjudgment in
my opinion instead he should have went
Castle now what are you going to do with
the bishop if you go Knight E2
then now I can go Knight
D3 Checkmate in one
move that's pul pul is racing yeah love
this where are you going to put your
Bishop that is the big question if you
go Bishop E2 then you're not going to
have place for your knight whenever you
go Knight H3 I'm definitely going to
chop that off and your Pawn structure is
going to be very very bad so vasher
misjudged the position I don't know what
happened to him uh but he's now in big
trouble wow I concur just like trying to
generate some play from the I was
thinking about the final position
position that we had okay yeah well
thought I was trying to generate some
play on the dark squares maybe some
Queen t7 Bishop E5 in that game and
perhaps try to get my pawns but it's
it's yeah it's a piece it's a piece a
piece is a piece uh let's just uh jump
to uh the game between Fabby and Wesley
because
uh promising saw H5 G4 B5 came I'm a
little bit surprised by the move Bishop
A3 uh that to my eyes is a very
committal move and I was really
anticipating this bishop moving actually
in the other direction to F6 so I like
Christian starta very
G4 uh B5 let's just say something uh
similar to the game position
and here you can make the move Bishop A3
if you think the bishop belongs on that
diagonal but I really thought the bishop
was coming the other way yeah yeah I I I
agree I'm surprised at the town of
events it's like somehow Bishop a of6
seems to play itself yes because Rook e
3 is such a aggressive move you know it
signals the intention meanwhile I think
Bishop A6 is a little bit what is the
Bish I mean I I don't understand I'm not
sure what the bishop and that's actually
very sely in question what is the bishop
doing on D6 looking pretty it looks very
very pretty the bishop is not doing
anything on D6 and by the way uh same
point for um White's G2 Bishop you can
look at that bishop and say what are you
doing I guess I guess he wants to now
switch to an end game approach you know
try to trade off all the pieces and and
win the a takes A4 and at least in this
case yes the bishop does have a role
yeah so intriguing things happening in
that game and again I just want to bring
us to the game of the world champion and
look at what grishuk has done uh a
moment ago I was going for this H4 to
disturb this bishop that's sitting so
snugly on G6
grook F4 talk about commitment tra the
bishop yes right so here we go F4 F5 is
a massive threat and please allow me to
sacrifice upon PA after E6 F5 the
triplets are you're not going to enjoy
the triplets there for black so uh
Magnus felt himself compelled to play
F5 uh I suppose the same thing goes on
if you were to take then take off to E6
I'm going to
immediately right play for F5 so Magnus
played F5 but at the same time he just
buried his Bishop on G6 this bishop
could become a fixture of just looking
like a massively big pwn and we have
this position and what do you think
about the move H4
guys I mean I've got it on my mind
absolutely what do you think about this
do you want to bury the bishop even more
precisely I'm trying to hope
that or something H well let's say H6
your Bishop may never see the light of
day right and if you play H5 the same
something similar uh well the computer
doesn't necessarily like this move H4 uh
for a very specific reason I'm going to
play H5 you are okay and next few moves
are going to be F6 controlling the
important G G5 and E5 square and then
I'm just going to play E6 defending the
F5 pawn and then my Bishop in the future
in a potential end game is going to go
back to E8 to B5 try to exchange it and
uh and the position is a little bit
closed black has the G file that's
extremely extremely and H4 then
undermines the G because you want G G4
and E4 you want that square for the
night most probably the the the H4
square but there's a there's a very uh
funny uh intriguing element in the
position if you think of the position as
a Dutch Stonewall for a moment Black's
light squared Bishop has done a dance to
the king side which normally you applaud
and then it makes an effort to come back
to a starting position
on the queen side and in fact those
moves have been played H4 has H4 H H has
been played yes H5 H5 is forced yes AB
Magnus did play it if the webcam looked
right and you make a very good point
there Christian that if you put the if
white puts a knight on
F3 uh hoping to hop to E5 then F6 cover
cover cover the Bas just in time right
and I can't I'm I need need to do
something to I really want to open up
the blast open the position now so B4 B5
okay let's let's take a look so I jump
Knight
F3 should we start with E6 or F6 guys we
have some uh some recent developments in
this game between the two Frenchmen
backro ATN and bashier lrav check this
out backro has only six minutes left on
the clock that's a huge lead for vasher
he still has the bet well actually not
Rook takes
D2 he completely missed this move after
Rook takes D2 Queen takes
C3 Rook B1 Queen takes C1 Rook takes C1
Bishop H6 I grabbed another PA I'm going
to have three pawns for your piece and
uh with low time with low time on the
clock this is going to be a difficult
defense for white I remember yes
remember he doesn't get time at it he
get it's it's simply a delay exactly
and vasher played it he played Rook
takes D2 of course he's very brilliant
tactician vasher so yes Rook takes these
guys I mean it's like just a flick of
the eyes and they just see these uh
tactics they just yeah it's second
nature to them I think it's because all
of the Millennials today the young young
players they they have these tactics and
they just that's all they do is solve
tactics half their days training well he
mentioned actually in an interview some
in some tournament he said you know he
recommended for someone to improve just
do two hours of tactics that's what he
did really two hours of tactics a day
and and then he was very blaz as to the
actual amount of opening work he did but
uh yeah his recommendation was and here
you can see it's paying off indeed it
has so uh with the time we understand
that etan in trouble sorry and I
actually think uh black is not going to
take with the queen on C3 I think he's
going to take with the bishop we want to
preserve the Queens on the board with
low time control the Queens are very
important a big factor uh of attack so
after Rook D7 not Rook D3 definitely not
Rook to D7 Bishop takes A1 Queen takes
A1 guess what C3 is coming that c Pawn
looks very very menacing I don't see a
backro getting out of this no things
really went wrong uh in allowing this
tactic uh that MBL just executed very
quickly in fact and we haven't looked at
it that much in fact we haven't it at
all but the Sergey kakan versus vesselin
topof game is certainly intriguing how
okay it all came from a Joko piano which
is which is grandm standard exactly
stampeded the Chess World it's like the
the uh opening for white in 97 basically
challenging white to say are you intent
on giving up your Bishop yes that
question got answered quickly and thanks
to these double Palms on F6 and F5 white
immediately goes for the control of the
F5 Square since G7 G6 is no longer
playable C6 Queen H5 D5 this all looks
very
straightforward and well we were taught
that um these positions really favor
White
okay and let's go to Paris yes let's uh
hear what Maurice and Rain have to say
what developments do you
bring well of course everything has just
gone crazy on this all French matchups
so of course I'm bringing in the
Frenchman watching this as his
compatriots battle it out Roma this
position you saw eten have just a little
bit of time on his clock and then he
played this horrific move Knight to
F2 yeah I
mean Maxim was not extremely convincing
after his excellent pie sacrifice in the
opening and well before the move Knight
F2 well it looks like white is just a
piece up of course black has two pawns
and a a nice coordination so this is not
like black is lost but I think white is
better you actually said that you feel
like you would just be winning if you
were in this position yeah well it was
probably an overstatement but uh I would
think I we overstate all the time I mean
exactly especially French but yeah sir
yeah sir especially so yeah um but still
of course with s minutes uh versus 20 uh
Maxim was probably still the favorite in
that game and uh here well Ian played a
very natural move Knight F2 which turns
out to be a big blunder he should have
played maybe Knight G3 or KN F4 uh
Knight F4 with the same with a similar
idea but he play Knight F2 which is uh
which is let's say a human move but you
have a look this big trick by Maxim
Bishop E2 Rook takes C2 and Rook takes
D2 and now black is much better okay he
has to take uh well he took with a rook
I think in the game but uh doesn't
matter what he takes with Bishop takes
C3 uh and then black is going to take on
A1 and the position is very different
first of all it is three pawns but also
White had this fantastic Pawn on ti3
that was kind of blocking everything now
it's gone uh it was a Super Pawn and now
it's gone and uh the C4 Pawn was just
advance and well maybe this is still
holdable for white but without time in a
rapid game I think black is going to win
that quite easily this looks bad
definitely for M for the Frenchman eten
Bako in his first first Grand chest T
event let's go down to a couple of other
games let's bring up this game Magnus
Carlson what do you think about this
position if you may press it just for a
moment there please and this Pawn on G6
guys is not the I I say Pawn because I
mean look at it that piece is horrible
but he felt the need to play this move
quite several moves back here after this
move F4 was played it looked like he was
going to get rolled with this F5 move
and he played F5 himself this current
position just looks absolutely horrific
for the world champion I'm not that sure
actually it looks a little bit like
there is some line in the Queen's Gambit
uh well the Queens are traded so it's a
little bit different but this bishop one
day in some ending can come back into
the game uh let's say F6 Bishop B8 and
uh well this is still quite solid for
for for black uh I'm not so sure about
this move H4 actually I don't like it so
much because I think um well I think uh
especially with Queens on the board when
white will Castle short he would like
very much to play H3 and G4 uh so I'm
not completely sure about this move H4
on the other hand okay like you say
after H4 this really looks like a pawn
so okay this let's say this has some
plus pluses and minuses yeah I can't
tell that it's a bishop right now guys
it just it looks awful well we will be
continuing to bring you more nuances
here as the action now is getting to
that final phase of the game here in
Paris thank you guys and Christian what
is uh track te uai in this first round
of the grandchester we we have some very
very explosive developments in the game
between the two Americans Fabiano Carana
and Wesley so in this position Fabiano
play the move Rook H1 looks very natural
you put your Rook on the H file you
prepare H takes G6 and some attack on
the H file the problem is and Wesley
didn't do this Rook takes C3 Rook takes
C3 Rook takes C3 Rook takes C3 and now
only move because otherwise I'm going to
play H6 and then I'm going to go Rook B1
threatening Rook B8 check m g takes H5
this would have been uh The Killing move
and uh black is having quite quite a
nice Advantage quite quite a nice
advantage in this position um because of
the weakness of the D4 Pawn I can play
Queen D Queen A7 Queen A6 infiltrate my
queen on E2 then break uh your kingside
Pawn structure with H4 and uh the white
king is going to be in trouble so Wesley
could have grabbed the initiative
instead he played the move King G7 which
allows uh White to consolidate with a
move Bishop C5 though I still prefer
black because of the pawn
structure wow intriguing uh thank you
Christian that is uh double-edged it it
it it seemed
counterintuitive to give up the two
Rooks just because you look at the black
king and you think oh my God I could get
and also G takes H5 is very opening
opening the position but when you kind
of delve deeper I guess you see that the
Rooks are uncoordinated the bishop on G
five is a great piece good defensive
piece and you have these two wonderful
passes on the a line and I'm looking at
another game uh one of my dark horses uh
Mami Dar versus Hikaru that was the
bononi where I thought that black had a
pretty comfortable position aaro had the
space aaro went B4 and Shaq said I'm not
playing B6 and playing for some equality
I'm going to Counterattack with this
B5 it's a great move it is a fantastic
undermining move you know undermines the
D5 Pawn this and it perfectly fits in
the spirit of the bononi in the bonon
you don't sit back and say I'm going to
hold the position no no no no you have
to play uh full out for the initiative
and after I'm surprised with this Knight
D4 actually what did you expect well no
actually I know I'm not well I'm not
surprised by this but I I I'm surprised
with what what happened afterward
thereafter okay so obviously Knight D4
if you can sink a knight on C6 okay then
you're then you're boss okay so B5 was
actually the best move C takes B4 a
takes B4 and then B5 opening up the
center if you would have played B6 as
you recommended the the problem is B5
what are you going to do with this
Knight on C7 he's not going anywhere and
you're still going to have this weakness
on D6 long-term Initiative for for white
A4
e if you manage to get rid of this
Knight exchange it or some somehow uh
open up the center undermine the pawn on
D5 and then grab the pawn on D5 with the
Knight then you're going to be perfectly
fine as black and that's exactly what
happened in the game in this position it
is white who has to be very very careful
uh not to lose not to get on the
defensive side that was exactly uh our
impression is um we were looking at what
happened as the game unfolded move
Knight D4 turned out that it didn't uh
meet the requirements of the position
after a trade rookie eight change now
suddenly oops be very very careful about
grabbing a pawn yeah there's a check on
the back rank uh iaru felt compelled to
back up with his Knight Knight F3 and
now came this Nifty move into the corner
yeah that's and he found a fantastic
move A8 uh look eyeballing the pawn on
D5 then came H2 H3 making lift and now
Bishop F defending with the chop chop
chop what are you going to do about your
D5 pawn and Hikaru found what Chris
fantastic move Bishop C1 Bishop C1 the
only move in the position to keep the
balance uh in place because you want to
put your Bishop to f8 you see
consequences consequences of moves what
was the consequence of the move Bishop
f8 he left the long uh the long diagonal
so after Bishop f8 Hikaru immediately
asks questions what are you going to do
on this diagonal if B takes C4 Queen
takes C4 Knight takes D5 you are a pawn
up but I'm getting a lot of initiative
for it uh I think I can even play B5
first maybe potentially play Queen C6
and uh get the pass Pawn on C on C6 then
Bishop B2 Knight G5 Knight E4 targeting
the F6 square and the D6 Square I think
Hikaru has enough compensation for
equality wow and I live for pawns oh
dear oh dear I'm not sure I'm not sure I
would I would probably grab that PA well
you have
to right both players are writing the
tiger here I mean the pawn sacrifice
very very enterprising and you've been
pointing out the initiative that white
has uh Christian and uh it's got to be
said there is uh compensation for H Caro
No Doubt
but but very well placed pieces I'm not
that I'm not 100% and they are bling
look at the time 8 minutes to six we're
reaching crunch time I think crunch time
is honest and this is exactly what
happened uh Hikaru uh M arov took the
pawn hikaro put the bishop on the long
diagonal and now Bishop G7 is the
natural move right but after Bishop
takes G7 King takes G7 Knight to G5
again Knight goes to E4 targeting the D6
Pawn I think this is just going to
liquidate into an equal end game instead
of Bishop G7 the only move to preserve
some sort of Advantage is actually
Bishop to E7 W oo to stop Knight G5 yeah
bit bit of a strange move in my opinion
obviously Queen D4 is is not a good move
because of Bishop F6 so this Knight on
D5 in the center is is is very well
placed controlling the dark squares
around the king and helping black um MH
keep control over his King basically
right but you mentioned a nice idea
there instead of the move Queen D4 you
mentioned that B4 B5 pressing the C6
Square keeping the A7 Pawn under control
could well okay let's see Bishop B2 and
that's not that's not the only reason B5
you're also planning on playing Bishop
A3 and actually targeting the pawn on D6
so for example if Black Goes uh Bishop
G7 then Bishop A3 then bishop f8 and
then maybe I can play Bishop smug the
tempo
yeah5 intriguing and what else is
catching your eye any decisive moments
going on can we check out the Magnus of
course
Magnus with with a lovely Bishop G well
you anticipated very well Christian that
what Magnus was going to have to do
after this move Knight F3 take look at
the time f look at the gista is playing
on 3 minutes minutes minutes is addicted
to playing uh with three minutes with
one minute with complete time trouble no
human would be able to play those type
of uh brilliant chess in in that time
situation and by the way Magnus uh took
a page I always love these Maneuvers
very very much I I I'm trying to
remember the first time I fell in love
with this maneuver Rook ag7 along the
seventh ring I think it blanca game I I
saw a defensive maneuver and since then
I've called it the Kappa Blanca defense
because you also see it Rook A7 yeah
Rook this comes all the way to G7 right
how very very nice okay and then we have
Rook H7 Queen B3 Knight Knight that
wasn't the first move that came to my
mind Knight A7 Rook H3 oh my goodness
Rook E7 and okay what what do you make
what do you make of this position I'm
confused I'm I'm just F the whole Rick
action a bit
hysterical H7 Rick H3 come Rook G3 and
let's move to Paris to see what uh
Maurice has to share
Maurice well there's just some exciting
variations in the game with the
All-American matchup that we are looking
at here and just spectacular indeed Roma
this possibility for Fabby and the
engines are going crazy saying that with
this concentration of forces although
black has destroyed White's Queen side
it's certainly the king side that counts
and there is the move Rook to F6
threatening a monster sacrifice on the
H7 Square this move Roman looks really
enterprising yeah it looks it yeah it
looks really strong and of course it is
exactly in the spirit of the position
and he has played it as a matter of fact
I just saw out the corner of my eye the
move has been played okay so probably
black has to take it because there is a
terrible threat uh Rog takes H7 check
here uh well everything was everything
that happened was in the spirit of of
the position that white kind of
surrendered everything on the queen side
and placed his pieces excellently on the
on the king side and now rck F6 is
exactly what should happen this is
exactly the way for white to make this a
success and now yeah we were looking at
some crazy line you may continue yeah
let's go into the lines takes takes and
of course now this King doesn't want to
get flushed out you take this pawn and
this check is uh not so pleasant to have
to look at in fact uh there are probably
other things to look at as well but
that's the killer move Bishop E5 check
follow by taking on 87 so that is
crushing we would expect him to drop
back after ef6 with this move and this
is the moment when the key move occurs
exactly because it it looks like white
has a control of the light squares uh it
looks like Queen F7 is coming and what
is next and now white has a very
important move Bishop E7 straightening
F7 check and of course preventing uh
Queen F7 that's a money move F7 check
with Rook takes on tap uh certainly
there's a lot of pressure on this side
the E6 Pawn is suddenly under attack
this has to make Wesley feel EX
extremely hot under the collar this is
the variation he's certainly inspecting
he might have to just toss this rook in
on the fa square and go hope for the
best in this line but remember we've got
to be liking white in this game yeah it
looks uh terrible for black actually now
I see that even the computer is saying
Rog B1 is completely winning but we're
also looking at Bishop takes f8 uh Queen
H3 G5 And Rog to B1 and well even if
white is not winning in practice it
looks completely winning Fabiano Carana
he was my pick I told you I saw
something in his eye trying to get some
revenge for this that has happened so
far for him this year playing extremely
enterprising chess Rook F6 a spectacular
sacrifice indeed well you got to love it
playing move like Rook F6 you always
feel good but look at the game between
Magnus and grishuk grishuk underneath uh
a minute and a half what is he down to
he's a minute and six 1 minute and six
seconds seconds and a really awkward
game for both sides sides actually to
play but uh it feels like grishuk uh was
double guessing his Rook H3 sorte and he
lost a few Tempe but the game is very
very blocked hard to say who has
anything uh serious in the position
maybe it's still balanced I think
objectively they still balanced but I
think I like black I like Black's
possibility of going nice I think you
like Black's time no no no no no no not
I like the squares I like the E4 Square
you know because this is something that
white will have to calculate in every
move a knight coming into E4 and the
consequences of that and the fact that
the E5 square is covered the E5 square
is covered my Bishop I think is a bit of
a sleeping giant do you know if he gets
to B5 you know just just a you know just
a trade I'm also thinking if if for
instance after Knight E5 Knight E4 check
sorry yes and then forc to trade you're
forced to trade and then my Bishop comes
into its own little these are kind of
possibilities that I think white they're
not to De yeah they're not they're not a
threat now but I call I like to call
them ghosts they ghost lurking away
right you get nervous by these ghosts
right and and white doesn't have an
entry
point Christian you're you're what's cut
you eyes yes let's go for uh just one
second to uh the most fire on the board
game the one between backro and vasher
in this position backro played the move
Queen C2 setting up a trap and
unfortunately for black he played the
move Queen D7 which is already a bad
move instead of that he should have
played the move Queen C6 similar idea
you're defending the uh the A4 Pawn but
there's a huge difference after Queen D7
white found this move A3 oh no the pawn
on C3 is no longer defended so now if
you take this would be a huge mistake
Queen takes C3 Queen takes A3 then your
position as black collapses because this
Pawn on A4 doesn't mean anything so um
after Queen D7 A3 I think the only move
to try to um get equality is Rook D2
Rook takes D2 Queen takes Queen takes D2
que oh yes imag imagine calculating
calculating all this with one minute on
the clock uh this is exactly what Ean is
uh is needed to uh to do in order to
make a draw after Queen E4 C2 and now we
get the perpet ual Queen E5 King G8
Queen B8 King G7 Queen E5 with a draw
still some traps along the way but uh I
think back row might actually survive
wow and that would be a very narrow
Escape indeed and back to
Maurice oh not back to
Maurice
okay let's try it again let's try it
again okay Maurice from the
top well we are here and we are here
with this position this is a critical
position in the game and Fabiano Carana
not only missed a win he has blundered
so horribly that he is now dead lost man
this is this is just going to be very
sad for him because he played such a
beautiful sacrifice and he could have
continued it with one of the great
brilliancies especially in Rapid chess
of his career this fin would have been
spectacular exactly he had to continue
in The Same Spirit uh as he's playing
from the beginning of that game and uh
well Bishop D6 is uh he play definitely
something he should not do as you see
the engine go down and now C3 is just
hanging lose it's a question what he
what he missed actually did he miss Rook
takes C3 did he think that the Rook has
to to remain to remain on the seventh R
have no idea and here indeed he missed
this beautiful win F7 check now this
move itself is quite natur natural if
you look at it because you're going to
break through the square and here maybe
he was thinking that he would get
nothing if he just promoted and that's
all he looked at but right now he has
one of just the great moves you'll ever
see absolutely spectacular response
unbelievable yes probably actually there
are two wins Queen G3 but also Queen E3
probably it leads to the same to the
same same ideas yes Queen to G3 folks
Queen G3 hanging the bishop hanging the
pawn and dropping in on E5 and the
variation runs that if you take this
bishop here comes a check if your king
now takes the pawn on this Square Rook
takes with check King goes here and
suddenly this queen just zigzagging
around the board and now this check is
the big problem you cannot capture back
because of this move Queen G7 and that's
all she wrote beautiful line this move
Queen back to G3 but also two moves also
here it looks like black may may have
for example an extra option to play the
move queen king D6 but then but there is
Queen E5 check Queen E5 check again that
Rook is just sitting on that row and
also there's another variation here
excuse me after Rook takes King to C6
but now your King's just awful and the
engine's giving Queen G7 E6 is hanging
with check your Queen's hanging the
position is just bust though with this
King being hunted down like uh like a
live chicken it looks bad this position
would have been horrible instead he
played otherwise if we get to the board
position now we have if you tick that
for me please this position on the board
and the engines are now just saying
dominating position for black he's got
in the move H5 his Rooks have crashed
through and there's no mating ideas here
Fabiano caran is going to be disgusted
that he missed this win thank you guys
this is some beautiful fantastic
geometry though I mean I I love that
makes Tess beautiful but uh the tactics
there just scintillating what a big Miss
but let's check out Magnus versus Gish
because uh Gish is on I I we left it
about about around these parts around
here I think he will struggle with
Bishop B5 was played takes A5 Queen E2
give me the pawn no says Magnus then
there was a trade of Rooks Magnus said
okay I don't like your Rook on C7 but
the trade cost uh magnus's H5 pawn queen
C2 King back and
176 15 and he doesn't get out of time
not at all and he's still and he's
running down to 10 seconds he's in big
trouble trouble oh 6 seconds the is
still equal but still equ King
G7 arresting this queen on H5 so we oh
he didn't play it he went Queen takes B2
and again he allowed the Perpetual I
think uh M pardon me uh grishik not
familiar with the delay he moved very
very quickly now he's taking the the
full measure of the 10 seconds okay let
me just refresh my
board then the Knight comes to Queen to
G7
Knight then there's a Runway H Pawn okay
and then it's a pawn race H5 B5 B5 oh no
it's not a race I'm I'm I'm several
steps six H six and somehow I'm going to
try to bring my queen maybe back to C8
right or maybe hover h8 very clever very
CL clever got you but then you will just
take a takes B5 and then you create
another pass Pawn the pawn on the B5 and
Magnus has quite an ample time four
minutes and grishuk will be playing what
about if he runs if he runs with this
can he find Sanctuary with his king and
the on the queen side you mean in this
exact position to kind of give up the
the the pawns on F6 and E6 yeah F6 I'm
trying to give F6 and uh I might give E6
but maybe not with check is it my no I
have I have Knight E4 this is I this is
my thank you thank you so if I give you
E6 as long as I don't give a a check I I
will play knight4 so in this exact
moment you're considering for example
King E8 King E8 yes right so and if you
take the pawn on F I have a nice little
Queen takes ooh you're nasty oh look at
this look at that those tactics Play We
love those uh Royal Forks so the F6 Pawn
is Untouchable so you're saying after
King
yes I may have to actually drop back
with my yes we have we might have the
first result of the round okay and
Wesley so just made it kowana oh it is
over oh my goodness what a huge
turnaround Christian take us through uh
the end of what happened in that game
huge huge disappointment from Fabiano uh
he started off so well he was pressuring
Wesley Wesley didn't take his chances
along the way and allowed Fabiano to get
a an almost winning Advantage
unfortunately he just didn't continue on
the same path uh he was on and uh then
he just uh made a few a few
blunders after King h8
F7 King
H7 Queen B7 Queen takes G5 Bishop
G3 Rook takes to G3 ouch F takes G3 Rook
comes down Rook C2 this looks like a
double position the problem is that
black has the first move he's giving the
first check and uh that's just game over
King F3 Queen to
F5 Rook uh King to E3 if you go Rook to
F4 Queen to D3 Checkmate unfortunately
you're taking away your own Square so
instead of that he played King E3 Rook
C3 Swiss Precision by uh by uh Wesley
and Fabiano after King F2 he just
resigned
C2 is inside of Rook C2 is forc mate
King E1 Queen 2 E2 Checkmate uh huge
turnaround huge turn around very sad wow
but uh lucky Wesley I tell you Wesley's
a tough man to beat and you know you
have to
play um I remember earlier in the year
the start uh the Tata steel uh it was
this game raor Wesley raor and and and
raor was winning yeah but one slip and
the game was in Wesley's pocket and
Wesley so our grand chest tour defending
Champion starts started with a win with
a win when Wesley starts with with a win
he's a very dangerous man yes very
playing catch up against Wesley doesn't
some some chess players like to read the
trends when you're lucky you feel that
somehow the tournament will be lucky
you're on an upward Trend right and
Magnus has not moved uh after Queen G 7
check he had 4 minutes to the 10 seconds
or so that grishuk and he's really
considering your idea King E8 and
reached for it oh instantly came after
King E8 Queen C7 not the move I was
expecting I was actually thinking King
E1 getting out of the pin and and
preventing this Knight E4 but Queen C7
came very quickly not a bad move it
actually forces the draw I think because
right now after Knight E4 Queen C8 if
you go King F7 then I'm just going to
follow you uh with my queen queen D7 and
now if you go Queen G6 I have this move
Queen E8 forcing the perpetual and
that's just going to a be game over
instead of that after Queen C7 perhaps
white black could try Queen B4 but now
I'm just going to start running away
yeah and I think is uh is black who
having some difficulties maintaining
equality in this position nevertheless I
think the world champion is just going
to go for Knight E4 pinning the Knight
forcing uh forcing the perpetual and
that's just going to be an quite a
explosive draw okay thank you for that
Christian and then we were following the
game of Hikaru he was playing with mamid
DAR that was the pawn
sacrifice and it does oh Knight F7 oh
let's stay with that Magnus game because
things are happening Christian take it
away yes thing oh it looks like a
Perpetual is going they're blitzing and
oh it will Queen B4 H5 was played Knight
to F7 wow let me just refresh this board
yes Knight to F7 uh Queen C8 King E7
Queen C7 King E8 Queen C8 shake hands
draw and it has indeed
happened
wow there were some chances for both
players in this game that was a how you
feel that Magnus might be a little bit
disappointed because the time difference
was so vast yes you feel somehow that
you could have perhaps tightened the
pressure a little bit Yeah but sometimes
you know it's the position but it's the
clock where you really feel like oh I
had him because of the clock but not
necessarily on the position seemed like
grishik always had enough counter
chances and uh how has the game with
hiar we have another uh very possible
draw in in the making between M Nakamura
and mamed arov uh as we've mentioned in
this position this critical position uh
black played the very natural Bishop G7
instead of the move Bishop E7 uh after
Bishop G7 everything exchanged King King
G7 Knight
G5 the Knight goes to E4 attacking the
D6 Pawn uh putting the Knight very very
centralized Queen D4 Knight F6 ideas
Knight F6 Knight takes D6 and that was
just uh well there let's actually see
what they're doing right yeah they're in
a night ending that looks like dead eal
but they're moving very very quickly
yeah it's completely but I they're not
using that 10-second delay very very
well uh they're playing all Tempo but I
think that's the way to do it if you're
going to win this if you're going to
hustle your opponent so to speak cuz
that's one guys they're playing night
versus night oh No Just King versus King
uh yeah okay I I still that's a draw and
uh well well they they played to naked
Kings and uh I must say by the way it's
a nice way to play uh an opening round
to really get you know the feel of the
pieces and uh Play The Naked Kings you
feel like you've done something yes also
kind of it depends on who was playing
you know psychologically I think it's
quite important if you say to the if you
carry on playing and say to the other
person well I'm only going to take the
draw when I want the draw you're
establishing dominance you know there
some kind of you mustn't underestimate
these psychological things through that
uh the game between etn and mvl has been
all over the map I'm sure the engine's
graphic has been you know like it's
unbelievable now that we reached this
position yeah we're into a queen in
three versus queen in two ending my
instinct says nothing for the extra Pawn
of course you like to have the extra
Pawn but having said that about the time
kinging what the king doing on C5 though
I was just thinking whether I could
perhaps sacrifice something with F6 at
the right you know the right moment at
the right moment F6 and and uh try
that's exactly what uh what bashier
tried to do by the way we're talking
another 14 seconds another yes another
in versus 4 minutes for
mvl and F7 F5 brilliant move by the way
brilliant move really uh in my opinion
F5 giving giving white a decision to
make with 17 seconds on the clock uh
that's very very important and these
guys are practical players they know
what to do they know how to ask the most
difficult questions and after F5 Queen
d8 no King F7 Queen h8 yeah and now
black
Starts Now black will start white
managed to find the the the defensive
resource by the way these Queen endings
are so difficult for the defender I mean
you got it's calculation calculation the
king will wander around you have to
think in the longterm goals can the king
hide
can they're very incredibly complicated
I don't think exactly so I believe
they've reached this position on the
board with with so much pressure on the
clock and of course this is a past F
Pawn um how would you rate Black's
winning chances I would have put them at
70% think really hot even though the
engine may be going 0 0 0 what about
yourself how are you getting your king
out from F7
though yeah well I'll I'll answer that
question
I'm vasher played the queen E7 now white
played King D5 blocking the king's
escape and anyway this King has to
defend the pawn on G6 so whenever I go
Queen H7 check you cannot really go on
E6 because of the uh the G6 Square so
I'm not really sure how black can try to
make any progress in this position
inrees well we're going to go over to
Maurice who has uh who talk to Nakamura
all
right well we have the winner of last
year's Paris Grand chest Tour event
hikaro Nakamura Hikaru you had a tough
opponent very hot opponent this year in
uh mov what were your feelings about the
game you played um I thought the game
was pretty balanced throughout um I felt
like there were weren critical moments
but I I couldn't find a way to put more
pressure on on shot and uh and so I
think it was uh a draw was a pretty
reasonable result I don't think either
of us really had much throughout the
game what are you feeling starting off
the tournament yet again you were this
was your stomping ground last year where
you had a very spectacular result yeah I
mean I was number one last year too I
think for the rapid part as well I
started with two whites and and I I drew
a difficult game against Vladimir in the
first game last year so um I'm I'm
looking forward to to seeing what
happens this year I mean I think uh
there there are many players who are
capable of winning so it should be
should be interesting to see what
happens
last question what's it like playing in
that studio it's different from last
year with all the big fans that they had
now a small Studio but trying to make it
great for French television yeah um I
mean personally I'm not a big fan I mean
I prefer feeling the atmosphere having
having people there gives it more of a
sporting fill for me but um obviously
they're trying something new this year
so it should be interesting to see what
the outcome is see if there are a lot of
people watching on Canal plus and and
all the other uh online broadcasts well
thanks for joining us good luck in the
rest of your games thank you hey Caro
Nakamura last year's Champion drawing
his first game off to a similar start to
last year let's see if he can repeat his
quest for the title thank Marice big big
div blund blunder and the final hour
poen Back Row versus vashir queen E8
Queen H7 bad move terrible move instead
he should have played Queen F6 King G8
and then just keep the king C4 King C5
King C4 and so on wait instead of that
he played Queen A7 King E6 and now the
problem is the queen on E8 is is a very
strong piece you're threatening the move
Queen E7 and the King uh finds himself
finds himself in a very very difficult
position he played King we've got some
action going on the board we'll just
come to the board follow the players for
a second
we'll oh but it does look like it's a
queen versus a queen versus some porns
well oh it's a it's
got a Pawn on G7 but how did that happen
oh my goodness no but it must be it's
very
easy
no I it's a this game has seen some oh
but now it's easy the king is coming to
G4 and the white white king cannot get
back in time to stop the H5
forame wow he gives him a smile that's
it game over boy but how did get there
because I we just saw that you were
showing how the queen was going to be
forced traded into a king and pawn end
game and it was just resign on the spot
I thought yes this is exactly what
happened after King E6 King D4 Queen to
D7 take here resignation was understood
well he was just uh hoping for the
opposition and try to keep the king out
uh from from from coming to the pawns
instead bashier played a few moves Let
me refresh my board
yes
and King
E7 at some point you have to do
something so instead uh black played
King C6 allow the king to enter and grab
these pawns but the F Pawn is going to
go for the queen king take G6
F3 King F7 King h8 and now the king just
comes back G8 Queen takes G8
King takes G8 opposition on the diagonal
King E6 King G7 it could have been
played it wasn't uh back Rogers resign
King F5 King F7 King G4 and now you
cannot bring your king all the way to H1
unfortunately destructive technique
black is
winning what a game and we have Maurice
we have
Carana see we'll see how he's feeling
after his uh sad
losos an absolutely a Topsy Turvy game
in this one and iano Carana with a very
interesting opening preparation it
looked like you got what you wanted but
then at the dramatic moment you missed
the win yeah I thought I got a very
dangerous position I played this line
once before against kaken and it's it's
extremely dangerous for black um I think
Wesley was playing more only moves more
less to hold on with King G7 Queen B7
and then I spent all my time calculating
Rook F6 I thought it was winning because
I saw this F7 King G7 and queen H3 and I
thought this would win and then I
realized at the last moment that King
takes s suddenly the tables are turned I
take king8 and I lose my bishop and um
and I missed that Queen E3 is a win in
you mean this position here where you I
mean F7 is is obviously what I was
planning and now I wanted to play Queen
H3 but that's not rooking after King
takes F7 it's just Queen H7 King a is
nothing and I just lose my Bishop so
instead after King G7 um oh sorry we're
yeah we're here F7 king queen E3 is
winning and The crucial point to see is
that rookie 7 I play Queen E5 King F7
Rook H7 King E8 queen h8 king D7 Rook
takes E7 and if he takes back I pick up
his Queen I mean it's still not he can
still play a few more moves after King
C6 but uh it is a winning position
disappointing result what are your
thoughts going into the next game um
yeah it's not I mean I was obviously
after the position I had I was hoping to
win this and um it's a unpleasant
surprise but how does a strong player
bounce back though still got a lot of
games left to play yeah there's so many
games and um I mean it's just the first
round and anything can happen indeed
anything can happen we'll see how it
goes as the rest of the games continue
thank you Maurice and what a way to
start the round the very dective of
Fabiano yeah cuz he played so
beautifully to set up that combination
and you can tell that afterwards he saw
this queen E3 as well so he's going to
be kicking himself and yeah you know in
a normal classic game You' go home you
get home after the match and then you
you think about it and move on now he's
going to move on very quickly exactly
three games uh three games left today
yes and we and go through our results so
we have had oh we'll have a Graphic for
that your thoughts on the first round of
play Christian well there was expected
quite a funny finish to the first round
uh in the game between karaki andalo in
this position obviously it's it's a draw
because the king cannot go out the king
is just keeping this King uh imprisoned
instead karakin play the move A7 King C7
and now he gave up his Rook Rook takes
C5 and this is just a state a nice way
to finish uh finish the first round very
very enterprising chess um we're looking
forward to some more very good sharing
he has a sense of humor exactly I always
like those St I like those kind of nice
touches nice right in staver we saw that
nice down meate too right oh oh oh oh
first round yes well very exciting I
think it's been very despite you know
there's been a lot of draws we've only
had we've had one decisive result with
Fabiano losing to Wesley so and the rest
have and that could e easily have been
reversed it could have easily been yes
and the other games have been very hard
fought yes and I I get the feeling the
players don't have quite haven't quite
mastered the time control somehow not at
all because again you know all of these
players have been raised on Blitz chess
and in Blitz chess you play Tempo you
match your opponent's speed and just
that 10 seconds is actually a lot of
time and they just not using them and
talking about our tournament game winner
mace with Wesley well early tournament
leader
yes and we are indeed with the man of
the hour Wesley so standing alone at top
the leaderboard Wesley it could have
easily been the other way around you
could have been in last place right now
yeah the man of the minute well that EX
last place I tied for last place withan
if I lost but uh but yeah I was really
happy to see him play Bishop D6 because
after F7 King G7 I
didn't que E3 but I thought white was
winning anyway but maybe your intin told
something was going on your spidey sense
yeah well because my my king is in real
danger and my protectors are so far away
on the other side well when I played
Queen B7 earlier go back yeah it was a
really bad move
because right here you played this move
yeah so that was a big mistake because I
totally missed that he would cut off my
king from the queen with Bishop E7 later
on so I should have played something
else like uh a CH or maybe just go for
this and then at least I W get M check M
indeed but at least you're in first
place uh in the tournament right now
well at least Ty for First with Maxim
Vash what is your feeling after such a
game is it a sense of relief or do you
feel like maybe the stars are with you
this one yeah well I'm very happy to do
the first game is like last year when I
beat Magnus in a completely lost
position so it's a good sign but again
there are um many more games I figured
we we'll play 27 games here in Paris in
total so it's only the first game long
way to go indeed well congratulations on
your Victory today thank you Wesley so
smiling he deserves to after getting
this Victory he is Ty for first going
into the second round and the trench
must must be thrilled easy for me to say
for were MBL and another game another
game that was decisive and very yeah you
know you saw a lot of blunders there
very tough tough indeed and I was really
shocked after Rook takes D2 a kind of
Elementary tactic
that MV allowed this A2 A3 and eten was
right back in right back in there and
but then still ended up going down still
ended up going down wow in a very tragic
way as well two decisive games but
easily they could have been more and
really hardfought games just what we
expected you know somehow in Rapid chess
and Blitz the players feel more free and
they're willing to take uh risk as we
just saw and I I love the start to our
grand chest
tour so find any any final Thoughts From
Paris if found any Impressions um let's
ask Maurice let's ask Maurice
yes well obviously we like it when all
the games are decisive but sometimes
chess ends in draws clearly all the
players are fighting in these rapid
games there are no easy draws anywhere
to be found and roma certainly the
Frenchman pulled it off well he was
playing another Frenchman as well
but certainly your fans are happy to see
him a top mvl that is the leaderboard
along with Wesley
so yeah well I mean he's definitely one
of the favorite in this tournament and
clearly well there were quite some
blunders in this game but uh you always
found a way to put pressure and pressure
and pressure uh and of course without
time Ian uh in the end collapsed du to
which was uh not such a big surprise
well indeed blunders are a foot in these
games in these rapid games we expect to
see more as we continue here from Paris
we'll be bringing you all the live
action thank you and uh yeah should we
take a look at the standing indeed let's
do that round one yeah so we have two
decisive scores with Wesley and Max and
as we mentioned at the top of the show
each game of Rapid chess will have two
points at stake and there you have uh
Wesley mvl leading uh the group and two
players at the bottom who both lost and
all the other people with one point yes
for their draws it's a very early days
anything can happen there but uh Wesley
was very pleased to have
escaped I tell you he's he's he he's
he's a man is so hard to
beat and Christian your thoughts on
round one before we take our first
commercial break of the day well
unfortunately none of my horses have
scored this round uh but I'm still very
excited to see wesle so doing well
vasher doing quite quite well he's a
very very strong Blitz player Alejandro
can attest to that and Magnus Carlson
he's starting slow but he usually picks
up uh in the later round so uh I'm still
I'm still very excited about what's
what's coming next okay indeed and what
do you think about Magnus first of all
he had black against a person you really
have to admire respect Alex angre it's
not that bad a result it's not that bad
results no I mean I'm definitely letting
the time situation influence my opinion
that's for sure but he'd be happy you
know black he hasn't lost he needs to
you know he put put some pressure put
some pressure and you know it was white
that groveled for the drawer in the end
and I think he'll he'll be looking
forward to moving on from that so
beautiful and we'll go to our first
commercial break of the day and we'll be
back in a few minutes for round two join
us
then
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Mai what's your favorite part about
this
sport I think the strategy how much do
you hate to lose I don't like at all
what about being second guest I don't
like that either well if I were you I
wouldn't have moved that
Rook
Checkmate sorry whether you've played
chess for years or never before come
experience all the sport has to offer at
the world-renowned chess club and
Scholastics Center of St
[Music]
Louis
he
[Music]
[Applause]
n
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
oh
n
[Music]
w
n
hello everybody and welcome back to the
first leg of the grand chest tour
2017 from Paris we're seeing the players
getting ready for round two and what
action we had in the first we definitely
had a lot of action on the first round
it was a very nerve-wracking I have to
say Joy boy I tell you if we can keep up
that pace everybody here on Studio is
going to be really happy and one thing I
really wanted to mention uh the grand
chest Tor we're doing Simo cast in
Spanish as well as French for the French
you got to go to the
canal for that but Alejandro andet yes
here in studio and St Louis are doing
our Spanish commentary as well and we
also have a Twitter feed hash Grand
chestor wow so you tatv Abraham she will
deal with
your your quote comments or your
thoughts and feed them to us but what
about round two parents yeah let's take
a look let's have a look so again oh
Magnus two blacks huh top board huh
Magnus is two blacks against Shaq sha
man so two of my favorites going head
tohe in this round two battle and our
two tournament leaders uh Wesley so is
playing against etan bakro who just lost
that MBA
Alex Alex yes that will be a crazy game
for
sure I'm will you know I'm willing to
bet a lot that that if if it's very dry
then oh it's there we go they're off
they're off they're off we didn't hear
the
G where would you like to go go let have
a look let's have a look okay um let's
Maxim versus grishik I think there'll be
fire on the board there let's see I just
h farad it out of my list of players
there okay Magnus on top Sergey Sergey
is in a and there we have it okay and an
open C yes but guess what it's mvl on
the white side of an open Sicilian both
of these players are very well known uh
for their black side handling of uh the
nidorf Sicilian but this is not going to
be a nidorf with the night on C6 maybe
we'll see we see and what has happened
uh Christian in this game um we'll move
it over to you this is a this is a
classical Sicilian in general I think if
I'm not mistaken White's main move is
Bishop to G5 absolutely and then there's
huge Theory it's very unnatural to for
me to see vasia playing the white side
of a sicilian he is basically the
trademark of of the nidorf Sicilian uh
Guk on the other hand he is a very very
strong nro player as well but in this in
this situation he chose the classical
Sicilian instead white diverted from the
main lines with Bishop G5 and he played
F3 I'm not really sure what he wants he
obviously prepares G4 G5 Bishop A3 a
potential a potential attack on the king
side um we are still uh very early on in
the
game and let's flip over to Paris and
Maurice Ashley Maurice let's find out
what he thinks over there in the heart
of the
action well absolutely it's definitely
an important game round two already not
that anybody's going to run away with it
this early but people know about Wesley
Soul's reputation he loves to take a
lead and when he gets it he will just
start putting his foot on the pedal and
this matchup is ideal for him Etsy and
bakro having lost the very first game
he's the lowest rated player in the
competition a wild card a Frenchman
allowed in he just lost a bad game to
his French compatriot so now Wesley's
going to want to prove something against
this what should be an easier opponent
for him than anybody else so we're going
to keep an eye on this game because if
Wesley wins this and goes 2 and 0 he's
going to make it very difficult in the
rapid phase for people to catch him of
course it's a long long way to go still
but like I said once Wesley gets going
he's the kind of guy who just keeps a
lead thank you m and really he's
absolutely right you get the wind in
your s
you you had a bad position you turned it
around you won the game and you got to
be feeling great about suddenly you know
the sun is shining every everything and
plus you're playing you know he is Ian
is the lowest rated player right and of
course you do pick who you're going to
pick on really yes you have your target
andm we'll have a tough time because I
think everyone will look at him and goes
that is someone I'm going to try and
score points of they they are sharks and
they sent the blood in the water I mean
I've had it done to myself in one of
these all Play All Around Robins y yeah
everybody's targeting you everyone's
targeting you making you suffer for
draws it's not very pleasant having said
that uh C4 E5 Knight C3 Bishop B4 it's
kind of been taking up a lot of
popularity I remember the first time uh
Alexis Shero was actually uh championing
Black's cause thought what on Earth is
black black doing he's provoking the
Knight to D5 E3 obviously this bishop is
suddenly a Target uh D2 D4 is on tap C7
C6 okay normally speaking the Knight
drops back and I've seen black
persistently chased his KN with I mean
it's confounding right you're Tau to
develop all your pieces andly I guess he
wants to double white Pawn structure
exactly get those double pawns and uh
Christian what game is attracting your
attention uh in this nice round two
matchup well uh very interesting
position in the game between mamed arov
and Carlson we all know that mamed arov
has huge problems with Carlson uh mamed
arov is a very uh initiative based
player Magnus likes to get that
initiative and then repul C to you so
that's exactly what he's doing uh he
played the I he played E6 e takes D5 now
e takes D5 minimal Advantage for white
black is going to play Knight C6 Rook E8
H6 get the bishop out of this diagonal
and then potentially Bishop G4 Bishop H5
Bishop G6 this is a very very equal
position for the moment but at any time
it could get extremely explosive if if
this Center opens up uh I think Magnus
has the upper hand already wow and here
I thought uh uh I like White's position
so in the position that you were putting
on the board C takes I was think I was
expecting Bishop E2 which by the way has
just been played so White's idea is very
straightforward the bishop on B4 pinning
uh pins the Knight on C3 to King on E1
so white wants to get his King uh safely
tucked away on the king side as soon as
possible and then jump with this Knight
to E5 and so long as he gets his King
out of the way this bishop on
B4 seems a little bit misplaced whereas
this bishop on G5 is actually very
annoying so I thought white was happy
yeah this really reminds me of a carakan
and a pan of variation where they take
they take with the pawn on D5 with a
pawn of course and there you know why
just enjoying a comfortable plus you
know because again like you said white
is going to play Knight E5 there's also
a problem with the black Bishop on C8 if
it develops to the king side and the it
leaves the queen side a little bit
exposed to a queen B3 Queen B3
putting pressure on D5 so there is
there's almost always this kind of issue
with black what's he going how is he
going to develop in the most comfortable
way yeah it still feels like it's well
within the confines of theory let's just
continue to some of the
Whoa We unorthodox position I mean
they're they're definitely uh we
expected up to C6 uh first let's go to
Parisa and Maurice Maurice
but we are paying attention to that
Wesley so game and we know that every
move in chess has some kind of drawback
every move you make even if it has
positive features it has negative
features as well this bishop to B4 is
welln to Theory absolutely normally
played but remember this bishop leaves
this Pawn on G7 behind now you might say
well so what who cares no big deal what
variation would you possibly use to
exploit this line but R this position
after Knight D5 Bishop C5 E3 C6 d four
and it looks like exactly what's going
to happen is going to be that this Pawn
is going to be
exploited yeah I think Bishop B7 is a
main move instead of Bishop C5 so we
would expect ien to have some big idea
when he played when he plays Bishop C5
but computer lies this E3 D4 for white
and uh well he thinks that everything
Ian has done afterwards is quite bad so
probably just played something over the
board come on now this guy's a strong
player you know him well why would he
improvise Right In This Moment he
prepared Bishop to B4 yeah well you know
it's rapid so he wants to have some you
know many players and they like to
invent something over the board when
they play rapid and uh well this is now
get and this is very possible that it
happened it also possible that they just
forgot what he prepared uh but okay all
I can say that uh is that computer Li
white that especially after cd5 takes
this check I mean I I can't even explain
why you would want to play this position
and now we see on move eight
we talked about that pawn on G7 the pawn
is now under threat what do you do about
this pressure you don't want to play
this move and this bishop is just
smiling gleefully in the position as
it's going to be a monster on the dark
squares this looks really bad already
yeah quinif for is like uh the cherry on
the cake we that is what we say in
French I don't know if you can also say
it in English we say the nail in the
coffee okay so a bit more brutal in
America already it would be some quite
nice compensation if I would play I
don't know B4 or Rook C1 or some move
but Queen G4 is like okay if you have to
play Move Like G6 or King f8 then okay
this is just too much because you're
underdeveloped and your duck squares are
terrible in your missing a dark s Bishop
that's basic chess we tell our students
and indeed he has play the move G6 looks
like Wesley so is already in the
driver's seat and maybe he's going to
play some more cherry on the cake moves
we'll look to see as the game continues
here in Paris like the cherry on the
cake that's nice some very honest words
by Roman well but so ear
etan's a great professional player eight
moves and already under tremendous
pressure uh after the move G7 G6 um the
player the commentators rather left it
because they just said okay great
compensation true that I mean that dark
Square Bishop is gleefully smiling
looking towards those dark squares but
you got to put together precise series
of moves if black gets D7 D6 that is a
Tempo and if he does get his pieces
developed Knight F6 he's still got a
pawn in the pocket you got to prove you
got to prove in modern day chess you
have to prove exactly so I'm not going
to count etan out yet but uh I do agree
however that D wh's Dynamics really do
compensate very nicely Christian what do
you have for us yes I want to go back uh
to a game that has the potential of
becoming the game of the round
between vasher and Guk two very very
strong nidorf players arguably the best
players in the world in terms of nid
theory after F3 e E5 Knight B3 Bishop E7
this is a game of
nuances the black played the Knight on
C6 but he hasn't played A6 yet so you
cannot go with the Knight on on D7
anymore but you can potentially play A5
in one move and this is exactly what
happened Bishop E3 C Castle Queen D2
Bishop B6 Castle opposite side Castle we
know uh it speed is of extreme
importance A5 Bishop B5 Queen
B8 and now I think we have G4 on the
board both sides are preparing their
attacks this is this has huge potential
of becoming the game of the round wow I
we always love these offens we were just
talking talking about how when child I
was a child I I I discovered this and I
read about this concept of opposite side
castling so as soon as I could soon as
see Castle King side Queen side castling
came and of course G4 G5 I love that
move and H4 H4 is another favorite but
you were mentioning that you were doing
this as a four-year-old as a 5-year-old
yeah fivey old yeah chess was easy back
then really easy it was so chess was in
your family then yeah it was a family
tradition you know my my father plays
chess and his father taught him chess so
my father was very keen that we keep the
tradition going so he taught my brother
and myself how to play chess four and
five wow another interesting idea in
this in this position uh black is really
having some uh difficulties getting his
attack going on the queen side with A4
so a move such as Rook C8 King B1 let's
say hiding the king all the way to B1
and now an enterprising maneuver Knight
E8 to C7 relocating forcing the bishop
to relocate and then we can go B5 A4 and
so on I have a feeling white is white is
just going to play B5 and he's going to
allow black to give up uh to give up his
Knight for the bishop and in the
meantime he's just going to push his
pawns on the king side so again if white
manages to contain uh Black's attack on
the queen side then he's going to have a
perfect game on the king side thank you
uh and just in that POS final position
that you had Christian after that move
90 uh I had this sudden thought of
Knight
C3 to
A4 trying to take advantage of the fact
that the B6 and if you went Knight C7 to
follow it up with the move C2 C4
consequences yes sir you left the C file
so now I'm ready to attack your C2 Pawn
ah
instantly the problem being yes if you
go C3 yes guess what bam ooh wow do you
understand anything from what's
happening yes King takes King takes it
to Knight C7 Bishop Retreats or I have
to keep the bishop don't I on B5 Queen
the engine's best move in this position
is Bishop to D7 wow because after Bishop
to D7 you go Knight B6 and you grab the
exchange or the bishop and then the king
hides this is madness on the board this
is I think this is going to become uh
the game of the of the round well you
called it early
undb also be very instructive because in
these type of positions as white I'm
always thinking how am I going to break
on the on the king side when you have
these Perfect Defense with the pawns on
F7 G7 and H7 the Beautiful the beautiful
defense yes and uh it is always a
question I mean often opening books will
just stop there and say great great
kingside attack mhm no yeah no give you
know show me how but you we were talking
about the pawn storms and how you like
playing G4 G5 and one of the things I
discovered just about the time I crossed
the 2200 threshold against a pawn storm
get your pieces out of the wiet so that
the pawns don't come storming down the
board with the tempo so I like that 98
uh very insightful move I I went to the
game of vessel and topoff versus Fabby
uh and played a French a French that's
which is close to my heart and he played
it in enterprising way that after
typical for vessel and Toof vesselin uh
more so than any other player on the
circuit loves the two Bishops and he
grabs them early and he's very
impressive with them having said that
the doubled B ponds instinctively who do
you like in this instinctively yeah I
have to confess I'm a vesselin yeah you
like the bishop I like the bishop
despite what you might have thought from
our
gamesday I do like the Bishops and the
pawns they play a nice nice role in in
restraining The Black Queen side pawns I
will worry about the Queen the king side
poor majority that black has later on
that's something I will think about but
for the time being I like the dynamic
play yeah and especially this bishop
could be a monster once it gets on this
long diagonal Bishop F3 controlling the
D5 Square as well uh the Knight C5 is
not stable there's always B2 B4 to
disturb but this is the kind of double
edged position that we were really
hoping for in the tournament one little
pattern I've noticed with the porn on B5
it uh it makes the A7 porn very weak I
always because it keeps it restricted
yeah so if you get imagine you get a
knight attack or a bishop on E3 and
perhaps it will hold down a rook on a
right right and then I like to do my
little math thing you know Bishop three
Rook
five good it's Auto this Christian yes I
want to point out a nice tactic in the
game between mamedov and Carlson in this
position mamed arov played the move G3
very very nice prophylactic move he's
he's coming with the knight from G2 to
F4 attacking the bishop on E6 now the
natural move in this position would be
Rook to C8 doubling up on the file
attacking the pawn on C3 and now comes
the blow Queen to E2 if you take the
pawn on C3 I simply
take take and guess what this Pawn is
actually not defended by the bishop
because the bishop cannot move after
Bishop takes D5 Queen to E8 Checkmate a
very nice tactic in the position and uh
after
G3 I think white is uh just better
because of this maneuver Knight G2
Knight F4 and uh black is going to have
some problems with the bishop on E6 yeah
nice trick there nice trick so should we
head back to the Gish game absolutely I
mean because that game was that game was
going to take off oh yes it already has
it was already yes yes of course in full
flight oh my goodness look at what we
have uh we we just left it around these
parts where Queen B8 was played G2 G4
move that okay go for
A4 uh Christian was mentioning it's a
little bit difficult for black to get
because the A4 Square was protected mvl
had no such Pro pardon me grishuk had no
such problems he just said Splat A4 take
it you want to open lines is D5 I'm
actually not sure what this D5 move is
uh I mean it's a good move um but it
Rook takes A4 would have been winning I
think wow Rook takes A4 Bishop takes A4
B5 B5 and that wow I'm not really sure
what uh what vasher had in mind in this
position maybe bishop takes B5 and grab
as many pawns as possible but the
problem is you're grabbing the Pawns in
front of my pieces and now I'm just
going to put my pieces attack your king
and uh I think you're going to be in uh
in in hug it's an extra piece for an
attacking isn't it that's absolutely
right oh my goodness so uh a big Miss
perhaps D5 D5 is a nice looking move but
if you have Rook takes A4 on the board
then you should probably play that I I
couldn't agree with you more that looks
like a Miss let's see what how the game
did unfold after the move D5 the natural
G5 get rid of that Knight no such way D4
I love this counter attacking yes
captures captures captures captures and
we're up to date but uh an extra Pawn
for white but he's facing a lot of
dangers as king the king is very unsafe
on B1 there's this Rook on eyeballing
the A2 Pawn so you can't really jump
with Knight B6 Rook takes A2 is a chill
chilling move I think I'm going to have
to take a a Tempo with King B8 but I'm
allowing moves like Knight D4 that was
Knight D4 here we go oh boy let's go to
Paris yes definitely
Maurice well you want a wild game that
makes no sense at all you want to look
at this one I mean what what happened
here you have to really think about it
before you could actually reconstruct
the opening moves if I were to hand you
this position it wouldn't be clear by
the way Roman that you came out of a
tepid C4 English like what's this but
now it looks like they've thrown up on
the board and we have a position Queen
C4 was the move play the engines like
the move Queen to H4 but after Queen C4
was played now this unusual move Knight
to A6 putting the Knight on the side
it's not even attacking the B Pawn it
doesn't seem to make sense and now comes
a very dramatic moment Rook to C1 with
the threat of actually capturing this
bishop
and here things get crazy things get
crazy because white has a very big
straight B5 of course he could not play
B5 on the Move B4 because then white
would have Knight C5 black would have
Knight C5 but after Knight after Rook C1
so the only not just Queen T C8 is a
threat but also B5 so here probably
black has to play himself a move like B5
and this is a computer s suggestion and
it's it's quite funny that after Queen
C8 Rook C8 Rook C8 King E7 Rook h8
that's three two Rooks in a bishop for
the queen many pieces but now of course
it is a white it is white that is uh
that is having a bad development and the
white king is quite weak so there is
some kind of compensation probably
doesn't work for black but for a rapid
game let's say this is maybe enough uh
to get un clear play yeah you look at
all these pieces over here you've got
the bishop the Knight The Rook nothing
really off the back row this queen we
know uh can be dangerous and yeah I mean
it it could develop into something but
it's not clear yet how they organize
themselves yeah I mean it looks like
there are some lines like this in
grinfield where sacrific some pawns or
even a piece or an exchange and suddenly
the white king is it reminds me of
something actually this position which
of course well not not the same position
at all but the same kind of idea and
this is uh well let's say this uh this
is the best can hope for after this uh
terrible opening it's important to note
this move back here why it's so critical
this move Rook to C1 and black is
thinking for quite some time castles
just simply runs into the move B5 and
you're just in big trouble U just make
it clear you're lost your knight can't
go any anywhere at all and if the Knight
goes to this Square then Bishop to B4
hello collecting everyone so the
critical moment in the game he is not
going to Castle he's going to play B5 or
B6 maybe or or maybe B6 he realizes he
has this trouble all the way back here
so critical moment for the Frenchman he
must be just feeling horrible his first
chance at such a big tournament playing
in front of family friends French TV
this has got to be very difficult a lot
of pressure actually not first chance
because he played last year already uh I
don't remember what was the result but
not in this tournament uh last year was
I think it did there was uh oh was it
first a maybe no first a play last year
BOS played okay maybe no no fresh and N
were the two Frenchmen who played last
year okay okay so yeah I mean it's quite
some pressure and of course when you
have to play rapid games against all
these guys uh were obviously extremely
strong rapid players uh well of course
it's a lot of pressure because you you
may Wonder okay am I going to win one
game in this tournament I mean okay it's
not so easy to beat any of these guys so
well he has a lot of pressure and
probably will have to play a little bit
more solid openings if he want to manage
something maybe to wait for the guys to
come to him and say okay you want to
beat me just come and then maybe to
punish them uh so it doesn't look like
this game started in the right way but
okay who knows if he finds this move B5
can become quite uh can become just
unclear absolutely enterprising position
we'll see what happens will the
Frenchman find his form in front of his
fans guys thank you gentlemen and
unfortunately for eten he really has no
choice he's putting himself in uh in in
a situation where he's got to give up a
lot of material for an initiative but
let's have a look at that and he has
played B6 we were expecting either B6 or
B5 and uh here's Wesley with the
opportunity grabbing two Rooks and a
bishop a bishop for the queen but again
the time uh control of Rapid chess you
really want to have the initiative here
you've got the game one I mean you got
massive amount of material but your King
still in the center but there's no you
know my still sleeping yeah all the are
SLE your night is on Jan your Bop is on1
your Rook on H1 your Rook completely out
of the game on h8 so I would I don't
know I I would pick black in that
position with an active Queen uh
combined with with a knight coming to B4
I think that's going to be uh
problematic for white say but I wanted
to ask the consequential question I'm
playing Knight F3 give me one or two
moves game over so how will ET he needs
he need he'll have to start with a check
find initiative check and you know you
got to go Whole Hog
right yes of course you are because
you're just you can't afford the problem
is you're not castling anytime soon yeah
so Knight C2 King King D1 no but I just
wondering whether I could I don't really
want to give up my knight so I was
thinking maybe I could play e E4 or
something you know four okay there you
go well if you give up your night the
most you can expect is a Perpetual right
that's your hope that you'll end up with
a
peret uh because also Black's king is
not 100% copasetic either right I mean
I've got uh ways of
annoying uh B total imbalance game yeah
yeah we love it we love it oh my
goodness I about the game of the round
you were telling us about to your
attention to a different game uh that is
between topalo and Karana Karana I think
he's going to make a comeback this round
uh in this position after Bishop F1 you
have to dislocate this knight from C4 to
be able to infiltrate with a rook on uh
C2 Fabiano understands that and he
immediately plays Knight to
B6 let me just refresh my board because
I want to make sure I have the right
position on the board after Knight B6
Knight Knight takes B6 the normal move
Bishop takes B6 6 Rook is coming to C2
Rook D3 Knight to D4 Pawn is going to go
to E5 I'm going to solidify my knight in
the center this is not looking well for
white white discombobulated his Bishop I
thought the bishop was going to come to
F3 I didn't think that the bishop was
going to go to G5 no this doesn't make
any sense to me it doesn't well I like
what you were saying yeah uh Yanka with
the bishop coming to E3 tying down the
PA Bishop really doesn't the future on
G3 and I don't like the bishop on F1
sorry I've got the wrong position here I
was I meure mesmerized by the game
between MBL and grishuk by the way this
is just uh a sicilian players you know
dream you know like massive
complications going on there but white
is upper porn but has two kns two nights
ver two Bishops but this is let's just
go back to see how we left it here I
like white we like white Knight D5 right
Knight C4 Knight
B3 okay so this is where vesselin and
then vesselin played Bishop G5 maybe
this move Knight C4 was no this Knight
C4 doesn't quite look right what's wrong
with B4 something getting your Bishop to
F3 but once that Knight took Roost on B3
also controls
line and I really like strategy you know
perfect Christian you called it really
well I think that uh he did play Fabby
Fabby has a really lovely position
especially with control of the sea line
the Knight looks gorgeous on D4 can of
be chased away no at this moment I think
uh permanent night as this the old
Soviets used to say well I think vessel
in with his last move King H1 has
prepared to move F2 F4 because if you
let that Knight just remain
there4 you know I guess that can be
stopped by with a that's a trademark for
all good players uh being able to pull a
comeback you know he lost a tragic game
in the first round again Wesley so but
now he's just simply outplaying topalo
yes with the black pieces all the good
players somehow find the strength uh and
manage to do that yeah I I especially
the world champions I mean you we would
joke that one of the worst times ever to
play Gary and Gary was never there was
never really a great time to play Gary
but one of the worst times was after he
lost then he was just like a
beast he didn't want to get into the
cage with him you know he was really
frightening uh what the heck is going on
in the Caro's game there's a missing
white Jeep on and I don't know what
happened looks good for black I like
that Rook on EO let's see what happened
it all came from a pretty conventional
Queen's
Indian and let's see there came a
capture capture oh so it was G3 takes F4
F4 takes E5 I was wondering how he lost
his G3 pawn it moved up the board uh
through captures and and now
hikaro it's okay well we should go and
check on Maurice and Roman
out there in Paris tell us what's
happening well it's it's just fire on
board that's what's happening incredible
game that you guys were following with
mvl and Alexander grishuk and this wild
Sicilian we love watching stuff like
this just as a recap after G5 D4
happened gf6 D3 Queen takes E3 and here
white ended up a PA ahead after Bishop
takes takes and KN B C5 so white is
ahead by a pawn uh black has the two
Bishops there pressure on the king and
you figure some kind of normal move here
except grishuk decided to pull a Bobby
Fisher and played Bishop takes
A2 wild why is the bishop in here you
know this is not a pawn we like taking
but it looks like this is very bad for
black looks like well of course knight7
and B3 here are two very critical moves
uh on the other hand well if probably G
shook probably G to really believe in
this move but on the other hand he
probably s okay A Move Like Bishop C8 is
not enough option and if he does
something else then white is going to
take on E6 and to play Move Queen B3 and
it's going to be just a pawn and of
course a very weakened SP structor for
black so he probably said okay let's
take on A2 and let's see what happens uh
this is in fact well of course with the
computer it's easy to see that it's a
plus 150 for white but on the other hand
okay let's say I play B3 then black
plays Queen B4 well from Human point of
view it doesn't look that clear because
for example move King B2 then uh Bishop
B7 computer says and it's the white
pieces that are starting to to be kind
of miscoordination little trouble with
some sacrifices here you can't take
because the Knight will be pinned so
there's but that's not what happened and
the critical line of course uh mvl
didn't need much time in this position
to play this one that long I mean look
at that four Queen Rook Bishop yeah well
the biggest problem is not the exchange
but this bishop because of course if you
if you can provoke gex F6 then white is
going to deliver mate with Queen H6 and
Rook G1 so yes after Knight D7 it looks
quite terrible for black first it
doesn't mind about this SE because A4 is
also hanging and then the white king may
become weak in the moment the Queen's
hanging he did play Queen here Knight
takes Queen takes as you mentioned is
best because Pawn takes is just going to
open a direct line to the king and then
a new Knight showed up Knight to B6 with
a threat on the rook and the Knight D7
threat and this is looking less like
compensation for black yeah this is
another this is another another I mean
another action this is not like taking
Knight f8 of course this is a real
exchange probably G shook miss this one
because this looks completely winning
for white simply um so probably Maxim is
going to win this game Bishop E6 was
played and now Bonk on the H on the no I
assume he can well Compu says Rog G1 but
I also well maybe B3 is also some kind
of move and then the queen to C3 okay
rck A1 checked I'm just going to ey the
king to B2 um if Queen E7 to give some
checks I'm going to play Queen C3 um
this doesn't look like a compensation
for black no it really doesn't look like
it at all mvl in front of the fans here
in France having won his first game
against his countryman well now it looks
like he's got it all under control
against grook and he could go 2 and0
this is a spectacular start for him no
doubt about it we'll see whether or not
Wesley so can keep it up in his game and
try to at least keep Pace with the
Frenchman round two we're are to grab we
are being faded and treated Christian
what has got your attention in this uh
let's go to one of the games that we
have actually forgotten about the game
between mamed yarov and Magnus
Carlson what started as a slower in this
position okay it's still very very
balance but Magnus found this incredible
tactical shot Bishop to F5 enticing
white uh to grab the material Rook takes
E7 now if you take back with the queen
on E7 Bishop takes F5 G takes F5 Queen
takes H6 this is game over your king is
completely exposed uh you have
absolutely no chances of survival
instead of that after Rook takes E7 I'm
going to play this move Bishop takes D3
now your Rook on C2 is basically trapped
my bishop and my knight are controlling
all the squares on the second rank now
this is where mamed arov is thinking he
can take on A7 but this looks very and I
think he actually did take on A7 this is
very dangerous after the move Rook E8
I'm still not going to take your Rook uh
concentrating all my forces on the king
side you only have your queen and the
knight uh on the defense The Rook is
completely out of the game so this this
might get very wild very very wild and
just continuing the thought uh do you do
did you evaluate this final POS the the
the position that you reached computer
says 0 0
Z I hate those computers I really do
it's it's it's double edged game in some
crazy lines for example Knight Knight
takes F4 Knight Knight F4 sorry Bishop
takes C2 Queen takes C2 G five attacking
the Knight and now you actually have to
take another Pawn take the bait or not
Queen E6 not Queen not Queen F3 not
Queen F3 Queen F3 is actually a mistake
because of Rook E7 my Rook comes into
play right all my now my Defenders are
coming back now my Defenders if I manage
to get my Rook back then my position is
perfectly safe the problem is that I'm
going to play Queen E6 attacking the
Knight Rook E7 doesn't work and uh in
this this position you actually have to
play Queen to A4 oh Queen to E1 King G2
Queen to E4 and as expected in these
sharp positions the computer manages uh
to find the
Perpetual wow yeah yeah you have to take
the Perpetual cuz there's a fork
happening on F
right6 okay but to see all of those
moves with such little time and by the
way jumping to the game of Wesley slow
also our tournament leader yes after the
move B7 B6 Wesley didn't like giving up
the initiative he didn't go for the
queen sacrifice very important I think
in Rapid player games to have the
initiative you know it's you force your
opponent to defend defending takes
energy so Wesley slow Wesley slow played
it with the move Knight F3 Bishop B7 E4
and he said look if I can keep these two
guys on B7 and A6 out of the game I've
got a rically one why do I have to do
anything special and I've got the two
bees and and the control of the dark
squares of course right so after castles
A2 A3 just keeping this Knight
restricted no Knight B4 no Knight C5 the
Knight is offside Rook C8 Queen D3 and
we are up to date with the players and
it's quite true if etan doesn't do
something very dramatic very shortly
white will just smother
Bishop on B7 is has looking at a wall
has looking at a wall the bishop on D
you know the dark squar White's dark
Square Bishop is fantastic Beast it's
going to terrorize the the porn and Eve
and one other point to just point out
when the Knight does drop back and the
Knight doesn't have any possibility of
Knight C5 now suddenly the move B4
B5 also introduces
another yeah I mean the could be a
monster on B4 suddenly trapping your
queen trapping the queen so at the 's
got issues and over to Paris
Maurice well of course France doesn't
want to see their homeboy go down like
that and so we ourselves were looking at
this position and there is a shot that
you have to be very cognizant of here
these Knights are so bad this bishop is
so horrible that you're thinking
somebody's got to go you got to free
your position and here A very wise thing
to do is to take on D5 and look for a
counterplay of course well here it is
white to move this is why white should
here play the move Queen B1 otherwise
black is going to take on D5 and to push
E4 next with a fork on the queen and the
Knight so I think what I think Wesley
was probably did not optimize his
position putting the Knight to F3 I like
I quite liked the IDE of the computer to
play put the pawn to F3 and then play
Knight H3 Knight F2 uh keeping a very
solid Center and then it it was very
unclear to me how black would manage to
get quter play well look like this
position it looks like there's some play
right mean queen B1 like y you're point
about B5 certainly there sacrifices on
D5 that are possible the engines giving
this move uh if you take back then E4
and sudden the game has dramatically
changed this is the move you pointed out
before so another move to get out of
this would be Queen B1 that's another
Tempo spent in this position and black
could still think about this move I mean
what else to do when your pieces can't
breathe at all of course suddenly
suddenly become the position becomes
quite difficult to play for black for
white for white sorry and uh well also
okay Knight takes D5 is an option but
after Knight H5 for example I'm not very
sure what he's going on because F5 is
coming Knight F4 it looks to me like
this is decent play for black I mean
suddenly everything makes some sense
because clearly uh may it be with Knight
takes D5 or F5 this uh these pawns are
not going to remain and black will black
I think black is now maybe almost fine
that Knight on F3 was indeed a slip on
his part should have put a pawn there to
keep that structure together against all
cost it looks like it's going to have
diminished it looks like it has
diminished Wesley's big spatial
Advantage especially since his King is
still stuck in the center of the board
with the bishop still on F1 time is a
factor here Frenchman fighting back
again he doesn't want to be embarrassed
two games in a row with so many people
in Paris and Beyond watching on Canal
Plus thank you gentlemen you cleared the
cobwebs I didn't see this Knight takes
D5 and E5
E4 and shatters the the nice white
structive strategical mistake to put you
Knight on F3 when perhaps a Pawn on F3
which is kind of a little bit well it's
very common in this type of uh structure
to go F3 but you know at this you know
you haven't developed what has developed
so the focus is okay we'll just go
Knight F3 of course bring the pieces out
bring the pieces out yes but uh that did
clear the cobwebs uh from from me
because I did not uh see this beautiful
sacrifice and then the position just
opens up wonderfully for black pieces
and guess what queen B1 has been played
has been played just as the uh as the
pros there were explaining I like okay
Knight H5 I agree that's a completely
Pro playable move but when you start
thinking about you know etan in the
tournament you know he's got the Target
on his back yes you know let's go for
the initiative I mean and theace
sacrifice a
decision to be made the question is do
you do it with so little time he's uh
he's five minutes short I like I like
being in the driver's seat the attacker
having the initiative yes please some
big developments in the game between
vasher lrav and Alexander Guk in this
position critical moment Guk should have
played Bishop E7 attacking knif forcing
it actually to take the the bishop on E6
F takes E6 this this opens up my rook
and in a potential end game this Rook is
going to be uh an active player instead
of that grishuk thought for like 10
minutes and then he took on A2 who would
do that an objective player would never
do that instead of that Knight
D7 Queen d8 Knight F6 Queen takes F6
Knight B6 very very precise calculation
by vashir attacking one rook and
attacking the move Knight D7 uh with
with a fork Bishop to E6 defending the
fork on
D7 Rook takes eight now the a file is
open the problem is that I have this
move B3 King B2 Rook A1 I'm going to try
to exchange all the pieces and then I'm
going to be perfectly fine as White
Queen E7 Guk is trying to find a
counterplay
unfortunately there's no counterplay
there and we've reached this position if
I'm not mistaken let no we have some
more moves on the board um the
assessment has changed a little bit now
black got some initiative uh still not
enough for equality for full equality
but there is still playing the game so
um we'll see what if gishu can come up
with some creative ideas well I must say
my first impression in this position
that they have is uh I like uh mvl but
let's go back with let go back to
Maurice and Paris mace find out what's
happening well a big development in the
game between mamadov and Magnus Carlson
as mamadov has blundered I want to take
you back just a little bit after Magnus
got this position he got the light SED
Bishop from his opponent and white
decided to play this move Rook takes A7
it's fine move but the Rook is offside
it looks like it's on the seventh rank
it's some pressure but it's offside this
move G5 Rook D2 The Rook was definitely
trapped anyway after Bishop E4 Knight E1
Rook to E8 and now is a moment you have
to stop and think about the position it
looks like everything is quite normal
but but black pieces are all perfectly
placed but in this position he blundered
horribly Roma with the move A4 yeah he
probably missed this threat Bishop F3
which is
actually which to us looks quite obvious
because we have the computer with us um
of course he had to play well he had to
prevent it playing some move like Queen
D1 and I don't think he was in any
danger black had compensation for the
pawn but probably not more uh after
Bishop F3 where Rocky to is unavoidable
and I this move is coming on the board
in a second yes and it looks like like
uh it looks like black is completely
winning I don't know if I play a move
like King F1 I guess black can play for
example Queen F5 yes yes and queen H3
and rookie too well it's ugly the light
squares are completely weak and again
we're looking at this Rook that's been
in tuned after grabbing this pawn and is
now on this A4 this Pawn on A4 blocking
it from coming into the act that means
that these three pieces are assaulting
these two and it's not enough to defend
the position he's in shock right now
playing this move seeing A4 land on the
board what a blunder Bishop F3 there I I
I want to know what's going on in his
facial expressions because this move is
a monster move with no reply at all he
is just completely busted right now and
you know Magnus is going to knock him
out the park there there not like Magnus
lets people off the hook of course well
he may try for example uh to defend the
position passively so let's say rocky to
is a threat so let's say move Queen C1
rck E2 Queen F1 but here I guess after
Queen E4 then rck E1 this uh crushing
the next move um yes mov a very strong
player 2,800 player he's been having a
fantastic year so far but it looks as
though in his first step into the grand
chest tour he's going to get hit by the
man who everybody picks to win this
thing Magnus Carlson bit of a wobble oh
boy great news for Magnus Carlson fans
Bishop F3 though what a o rookie two is
just such a cruncher I I didn't quite
get the at mvl versus grishuk position
because my first impression is I'm
looking at White's King on A3 and I'm
going oh that's rather nice I mean uh no
dark Square Bishop to disturb me and
okay I that easy it's not that easy
because I the first impression is Rook
B2 and it you know I got a B Pawn that's
just uh ready to trundle I didn't see
immediate counter my first instinct is
to go King B4 and just oh he played Rook
C1 not Rook B2 no he played Rook C1 Rook
C1 and then after Rook C1 uh G played
Rook F2 attacking the pawn on F3 now if
you allow me to take on F3 your queen is
going to be pinned so you have to move
this this King somewhere you can either
go to B2 or to B4 in my initial Instinct
would be to go to B4 to be honest but
after Rook F3 Queen takes
E1 Queen to G5 Queen attacking The Rook
but in the same time attacking the move
Queen E7 and now the king starts uh
feeling very very uncomfortable uh
instead of that perhaps better would be
king B2 but even so after Rook takes F3
Queen to E1 Rook to D3 or perhaps Rook
to B3 this doesn't look easy at all for
for for white in my opinion no yeah
that's not the variation I like I'm not
sure I'm not sure I he allowed he
allowed too much count well I'm not sure
why Rook C1 was played why didn't he
play Rook B2 cuz that looks so
straightforward Rook C1 is actually the
computer's best move if you go if you go
Rook B2 you I still go Rook F2 and what
are you going to do next okay oh boy I'm
not sure but let's go let let's go back
to Maurice
Roman well these French guys are
regaling us with their fighting spirit
in Crazy line and of course all of
France on pins and needles as they play
this game Wesley so looked like he was
just simply dominating aen bakro but
Roma he came back after this move Queen
B1 it looks like Wesley missed something
after Knight cd5 the sacrifice we
expected to see takes takes and after
Queen takes on D5 he made a mistake here
and play the move Bishop to
E2 yeah I think I think Wesley in
general um s he kind of overestimated
this ID Knight C7 Knight T D5 he
probably this is too slow this is why he
went I'm hearing I'm hearing that the
game with Magnus I'm sorry to interrupt
Magnus game is over Bishop F3 has forced
resignation in that game so the world
champion has picked up his first win
again continue yeah so I think he just
uh he just SOL this plan Knight C7
knightx Z5 can't work and he went for
this Knight F3 probably were thinking
should I play Queen T C8 or should I
play Knight F3 maybe maybe he didn't
think of this idea to just play F3 And
Delay even more development um and now
yes definitely E4 is a too big is such a
big threat instead of of Bishop B2 he
should have played the move Queen B2 uh
but again it means delaying development
which is not so pleasant because well
black has all this play look at all here
you want to play Bishop B2 of course but
Queen B2 was uh queen queen E2 was
necessary and here well E4 is not
working because Queen F6 maybe Queen E4
check Bishop B2 and here well Bishop A6
I have B5 but looks well looks very
dangerous Rock C2 is coming but I guess
I have Queen E5 well holding on barely
yes I would not like to be I would not
like to be white here on the other hand
okay
well computer says D5 which is a very
strange move uh D5 uh well a wild move
but that's not what happened let's get
to the game Bishop to E2 instead and
then E4 happened now this Knight has
nowhere to go because Queen B2 would
have allowed it to have a square Knight
to H4 and then G5 testing the Knight yet
again Queen B2 attacking his Knight
Knight E8 a sweet move no place to put
the knight at all so he just put it back
home and said what are you going to do
about this guy well guess what it had to
go back and after a couple of captures
Knight to G7 and and a rook to G1 and
now Guk sorry brro is back in business a
wild position for Wesley the problem is
there's a clock issue yeah he spent too
much it SP he spent a lot of time in
this game and now well black should be
better but uh it is not going to be an
easy task to play this position with
black I just came across something
interesting that uh computer was
suggesting uh here after move E4 instead
of playing Knight H4 and losing the
piece in bad fion is suggesting this
move Bishop E3 Bishop E3 which I think
is extremely smart and uh after ef3
Bishop F3 then at least white is not
weakening into spawn his spawn structor
and uh next move is Castle this is quite
smart by the computer uh like very
instructive move uh but of course Wesley
should not uh allow this to happen well
if you see if we all saw the position
like a computer did then uh you'd be
plugging in Us in at night uh to charge
up we're not computers Wesley so clearly
not one either he made a big mistake
here and now he has to fight for his
Life we'll see whether or not he can
pull it off as back Crow is in time
pressure thank you for that wow look at
the time W in trouble but a in trouble
in the clock exactly big trouble on the
uh clock action everywhere Christian
you've been following mvl and Alexander
grishuk what do you got for absolutely
action everywhere guys one game was over
one game could have been over if grishuk
would have found the right move in this
position white played King B1
and if C3 with the threat of Queen takes
C1 King takes C1 Rook F1 checkm would
have been played this is done game over
plus 10 uh by the engine Rook
G1 King G Queen G2 I'm uh I'm attacking
this Rook I'm hunting The Rook down Rook
to C1 and now the flashy move that
probably Guk missed Bishop to B3
threatening the move Bishop takes C2
Rook takes C2 Rook F1 and then if you
block with the Rook on C1 so let's say
for example you go Rook A3 I'm going to
play this Rook F1 if you go Rook C1 now
the queen swings back to B2 checkmating
the king this would have been huge for
Guk unfortunately he didn't let uh
himself enough time to calculate all
this and instead he played the move
Queen to B4 Queen to B2 Queen to C5 and
the game
continued in this position white is a
little bit better but while game
anything can happen all three results
possible but that was a beautiful line I
love that move don't you domate The Rook
The Rook down down what a Fant and the
way the queen swings able to deliver and
I just saw uh Gish giving a a quick look
to the clock uh as his time is down to
seconds seconds so uh how many seconds
is it five five seconds let's see if and
he's definitely nervous he just feeling
the the pressure of that ticking clock
he's still playing the most accurate
moves but uh his position is uh is uh
getting damaged with every single move
because also white is finding all the
precise
continuations wow okay and with two
seconds on the clock I mean you're not
going to survive that position two
seconds I'm not sure how many he has but
okay not more than five I would assume
I'm just trying to find the game where
is it is it at the top that's a Magnus
that's Magnus at the top that's a
backrow so it must be that's back oh
where's my mouse okay I need I
definitely need a mouse pad he does have
enough 11 seconds I think 11 I think so
got the board up on my and it's it's
strange to me that grishuk hadn't gone
for that C4 C E3 because you always love
those pawns on c3s and F6 right they're
right choking the opponent keeping the
king under lock and key and after this
move Bishop D5 he's kept the pawn on B6
under control he's controlling the B7
but it's really about the clock 5
minutes 11 seconds the 10-second delay
is that enough for Gish hook I think it
probably is I think it's not that so far
he's finding he's finding the best move
this is one of his brilliant
characteristics he he can play with one
second on the clock and he's still going
to find uh the best move in the position
you cannot gamble with him annoying when
your opponents always find but we got
world champion Magnus Carlson with
Maurice over in
Paris but we have the first winner of
the second round and Magnus getting a
win a much desired win with the black
pieces Magnus it looked like it was a
pretty reasonable game what were your
thoughts when you had the opening just
coming out of the opening I I thought I
was I was not too thrilled I thought I
was a little bit worse uh then I was
very happy to sacrifice a pawn and gain
some initiative and as you can see he
collapsed pretty quickly yeah this move
Bishop F3 you must have seen coming but
but to see A4 appear on the board must
have just shocked you yeah uh it did um
so I mean I didn't know what you should
play maybe I thought okay if it does
something like F4 at least it's it's
still it's still a game maybe also Rook
A3 is is holding but uh um no obviously
that was that was a pleasant surprise
indeed what is your feeling right now is
it still too early in the competition to
talk about your form in this in this one
um no well I think it's been it's the
first two rounds have been good like um
the first round I came up with an
interesting concept against chrisuk
fortunately I couldn't really make much
of it and this um um and at least in
this game I think I made the most most
of my uh situation all right well
congratulations and good luck in your
last game today thank you world champion
Magnus Carlson showing uh that you
better watch out he could hit you if you
make a mistake thank you Marice Magnus
is back back to business and nobody
nobody in the tour wants to see a hot
Magnus but that game of MV has captured
my attention the last move uh by uh
grishuk is Rook F3 and he set up a very
kg uh threat you have to be huh you bet
baby that Queen on e4 uh pitting the
pawn on C2 means Rook B3 is a Haymaker
uh White has to keep an eye on that Rook
on B5 doesn't make a very pleasing
impression for me it's The Rook on C1
the rook and
C1 yeah I think while that Rook is very
passive I think black will have no
problem just finding just generating
moves because that's all easier for
black play yeah the Practical
practicalities of the situation and what
do you have for Christian you're looking
at Wy we have we have uh some
interesting development in the game
between Wesley so and backro at and
backrow with 11 seconds on the clock in
this position Rook E5 White's only move
to keep the balance would have been
Bishop F3 Queen takes F3 and queen takes
E5 instead he played the move Queen
Bishop to D3 Queen takes to D queen
queen D3 and now if you if you take on
E5 the difference is that my queen is on
D3 I can play Bishop E4 attacking Queen
B1 Queen C2 and now you're having big
big problems uh instead of that saw play
Queen B8 and I think we have a few more
moves on the
board somehow he managed to uh find
equality but that's that's the problem
when you leave yourself only 12 seconds
on the clock you cannot calculate
everything and you cannot capitalize on
your opponent's mistake exactly and
exactly how much time does uh a TN have
at exactly 12 seconds 12 seconds o and
going down going down fast going down
fast no increment just time delay time
delay we'll repeat ourselves throughout
our broadcast because this is very
unusual of course very unusual and the
players there I wouldn't be surprised if
Wesley manages to Swindle him in this
position yeah and how much time for
Wesley by the way four minutes 4 minutes
and 40
seconds wle but just looking at the the
screen just looking at the shots there
he's playing very quickly as well Queen
F5 only move let's ah he played it okay
we got he's still finding the best moves
he's still finding the best
moves and I'm just looking by the way
also at the game between Fabby versus uh
vessel and topoff Bishops of opposite
color ending I thought Fabby was going
to reel this point home
it's it's awkward to say uh if he has an
advantage or not he's worse he's worse
he's worse already just a couple pawns
behind right three can I just what about
what about my threat of Rook C1 hey I'm
going to have to play H3 and I don't
mind playing H3 anyway because I'll
create a pass pawn and Fabby also
feeling the pressure of the ticking
clock
48 seconds for Fabby in that game but
let's go back this would be a tragic
start for Fabiano oh two winning
position butchering both of them that's
that must hurt that
oh yes no question about it still this
game of MV and Gish
Gish keeping with within with the time
frame doing a fantastic job of
maneuvering his pieces into good
defensive squares yeah he's still an
exchange up uh after all and uh the last
move I think was this move yes Queen D3
me too oh I just love the tension of
watching them I I love these webcams and
you're just right there look at the
clock 11 seconds yeah 11 seconds to 2
and 1/2 minutes well he had 11 seconds 2
minutes ago exactly but now he's
counting down to seven
six uh oh well it goes back to the 11
I'm not quite sure counting down the 10
oh I see that's what it's doing that's
what it's doing so I I got a bit
confused when I saw 6 seconds wait a
minute there no
increment gra shuk is actually uh still
alive and well
yeah okay let's just I feel why this
we're going to need the the the board
that keeps us up to date with the play I
love these webcam shots that is a
beautiful TV studio and Wesley's game is
over what was the result did Wesley save
a position that he was in trouble Wesley
actually Won Won Won yes yes let's see
how that
again Bak blunders because of the time
situation so in this position actually
black is slightly better um the problem
is that you have 12 seconds on the clock
and you cannot really play chess with
with 12 seconds 12 seconds on the clock
Queen E5 King F7 Queen D5 losing the
bishop and after after this it was all
downhill for him Queen takes D3 Queen
takes H2 and that pawn on B5 check you
cannot go King C7 because of Bishop E5
Fork King C8 Queen A8 Queen C7 Queen
takes A7 Queen D King D6 Queen B8 the
queen is going to be lost the game is
over so um yes aan bakaro a
disappointing result the second blunder
in the late stages of the game he's and
Wesley so is a lucky star as we start
these first two rounds my goodness
goodness oh oh my gosh Maurice uh
further
insights please well it's just
devastating after losing the first game
backro comes back and with great chances
manages to lose the second game and
Wesley you have to be impressed by the
way he plays he just always takes his
chance he always keeps his chances he
never oversteps he plays very
practically but if you give him a chance
he's going to jump on you yeah well uh
he took a lot of risk in this game
because well especially when he played
well for people who have have the game
when you played the move Bishop E3
computer was giving Queen D3 you could
exchange Queens uh but it would be very
drawish and he probably thought okay my
oppent has 20 30 seconds um I should try
something else but he went for something
that is minus five or minus four instead
so he took unbelievable risk and of
course uh well first I thought okay it's
quite lucky not to not to lose this game
but uh well that is true there was a
moment you're talking about if we back
up uh we're in the wrong game here sorry
uh no if you could pull that
up
right so way back when if we go all the
way
back way back when in this position
before he he stole this bishop which is
really unfortunate for
white I think I can get it a little bit
fast right here instead of in this
position here instead of this this was
almost ridiculous what he did in this
position because he did not have to give
away this Pawn from what we know this
position I played here play rookie a
which was ridiculous he could just put
his King here this is the most natural
move on the board like who wouldn't play
this move yeah and queen E5 Bishop B4
and now and now he would have
overwhelmed with backro have overwhelmed
him in this position this is where you
can say for sure that Wesley can again
thank his lucky stars for the second
time in a row now he sitting at 2 and 0
when he could easily have been half a
point or even zero yeah he win against
Fabiano he was dead loss and now this
one but this is rapid uh and especially
with this uh delay this brunstein time
control it's very very tempting when you
hop at has 20 seconds uh to do any kind
of craziness because well in well I mean
around there somewhere it would probably
take a draw if it would be some fishal
time control because any moment aten can
play five six moves fast and then get
one and a half minute on the clock and
if if if black is completely winning
then he going to win but with brine time
control any moment a blender can happen
until the end and we can see that in the
game uh many brenders happened
uh well good choice by by wasley of
course some luck but not only luck not
only luck strategic definitely indeed
and Wesley so stands a top the
leaderboard at 2 and 0 for the Moment by
himself this time the grand chest tour
winner from last year making a bid to
try to do it again thank you gentlemen
and we've got uh some really amazing
results Fabby goes down again get down
again 0 and two and this game between
mvl and
uh uh turning it over to you Christian
what is going on in this game we have SE
simply Madness on the board in this
position black is actually swing
swindling White Queen B2 F3 Queen B3
Queen E2 not the best move instead Queen
D5 would have been uh Bishop D5 would
have been better Queen B2 and now the
move F2 you cannot take the pawn because
Queen E1 this uh this Pawn is a huge
huge weapon instead black play Queen E2
Queen C4 and now once again he could
have taken the queen on C4 Rook Tak C4
and now Bishop to A6 oops easy tactics
I'm not really sure how he how a player
of Gru's caliber missed this instead he
played Rook B5 and I think we have a lot
more moves on the board right now the
assessment is as you guessed it z0 Z and
that's not going to happen at
all all three results of possible but I
do prefer gish's position but it's about
the clock it's about the king about the
Expos Kings they're both now down to 10
seconds and the uh players I think this
this favors this they swept the queens
and now Guk is definitely on the driver
seat yeah oh my goodness just just
looking from the video we see those
black has very nice pass pawns on the
king side what's more powerful than
three connected pass
pawns I didn't even spot I didn't even
spot the one on F3 but uh okay watch has
the the B on and there goes one
of very smart move by uh takes F3 by
vasher D5 check and there goes a rook oh
my The Rook comes back promoted and so
it's going to be draw bishop and two
connected pass bonds versus a rook and
since Black's King is so far the the
players have agreed to a draww what a
finish wow wow you don't know whether
this is a fair result or not you know
somehow they kept us on edges of seat
throughout that was an amazing game I
mean I think the players could you could
write a book on this game that was just
extraordinary a tactics book at least
well they tell us the results because
I'm like really confused we got Wesley
at two Z Wesley at two two and uh Fabby
has lost two gam in
a he's uh yeah last place and Magnus one
so he's one and a half so a couple of
people including vessel and topof at one
and a half and um M Dar lost of course
so he's a one1 well and then we have a
few draws uh Nakamura Drew karakin um
yeah Westley beat bakro and those were
the results but uh this game between
vasher and Guk that was simply Madness
and this is what happens when uh two
nidorf players arguably the best nidorf
players on the planet Clash um you get
this type of games so with no time on
the very very exciting round and let me
be quick to correct myself of course uh
these games have two points yes these
games have two points so it's actually a
four point uh for the leader Wesley so
has four points exactly at this moment
but that that was extraordinary you were
showing that one tactic that uh Sasha
missed of trading Queens uh and just
putting the r
theile yeah that was amazing because you
know it's an automatic you you you you
see the bishop on the diagonal well
maybe he was afraid of some B7 you know
that you could just decoy you're right
oh well we have Maurice with our
tournament leader
Wesley the 2016 Grand chest tour winner
making an early bid here in 2017 by
winning two games that Wesley you
probably didn't deserve to win it's not
how you drew it up at least when you
were back in the hotel room this game
was a little crazy to say the least yeah
well first of all a win is a win I don't
really care how I win I just want to win
even if I flag my opponent doesn't
matter but obviously I need to play
better than this because there are many
more games to be to be played um so I
need to have a a better momentum and
also a better strategy and a better
perform performance overall were you
surprised when he took on D5 when he
sacrificed and suddenly all had all that
counterplay ah well no I wasn't really
surprise because he basically had to
take on D5 otherwise his Bishop is
trapped but when played Bishop Knight C
D5 B5 Queen D5 I probably didn't defend
the best way possible because after when
I played Knight H4 my knight was
suddenly trapped and I'm simply couple
or a pawn down so I uh probably have a
better defense there I think white
should be better when he sacrificed the
piece but I just didn't find I don't
know what the best defense is now at the
end you could have easily preted like
just no problem at all bunch of checks
but you decided let's go for it and play
for Bishop D4 yeah played ah Bishop D4
yeah yeah I this I figured with opposite
called Bishops I can give a few checks
here and there but objectively at the
game of course white do no chance to win
unless my opponent blunders which uh
which he did
um so yeah quintex F2 was a terrible
terrible ban basically any move would
should have sealed the dra you're in
first place what are you feeling at the
moment yeah first place for the for the
minute well very happy I mean obviously
two out of two is a a perfect way to
start and I think I play better overall
when Tony reaches
around so don't leave all the way from
the US yeah but but again I have to play
better than this and uh in the in the
next in the next game but it's a it's
just a
good a good difference because in my
last tournament all my games ended in in
draw and so uh for for this one it's
just it's nice to start with two wins
but I have to play better well wild
chess you keeping us entertained at
least good luck in the rest of your
games thank you Wesley so a top the
tournament leader ship board right now
and I think we all perform better when
Tony Rich is in town guys back to you
thank you Maurice and congratulations
Wesley the smile on his face said it all
let's check out the current standing so
of course Wesley so in the lead with a
perfect score four points closely
followed by Magnus Vash mvl and Vaseline
topof all on three points none of us had
put Vaseline in our uh favorites but uh
he came back in that game with febby I
don't think he had a very good but he
certainly uh performed well couple of
players also uh behind with 50% theu
Gish and serge K and uh I guess the
surprise for me is to see
Fabby with no points big surprise yes
and your your take uh Christian after
just two rounds very very eventful
rounds well crazy chest is happening
yaser uh Magnus Carlson is showing why
he's the top player uh in the world his
psychological Edge over mamed yarov
played a huge role in this game mamedov
just collapsed uh Fabiano I don't know
what's happening with him obviously is
very very difficult to uh to miss two
winning positions at the beginning of
the tournament is going to be very
difficult for him to redress the
situation so um very very interesting
rounds ahead I think Magnus has a tight
grip but there's Wesley who has maximum
points so we might see a clash between
these two top players Wesley or Magnus
who's who's who's going to be yesk
indeed so what a way to start but we're
going to take another break as we get
prepared for Sor but before we do that
we have a video of yesterday's Opening
Ceremonies yes how nice all right so
enjoy the video and we'll see you after
the
[Music]
break hello from Paris we are at the
opening ceremony kicking off the 2017
Grand chess Tour all the best players
are here lined up ready to compete the
top players Magnus Carlson certainly
someone who is a favorite in this event
but everyone is extremely powerful the
drawing of the Lots certainly lining up
the competition and they are ready to go
after the drawing of the Lots the
players got to have a bit of fun playing
in the proam event some amateurs pretty
distinguished amateurs getting the
opportunity to play with the best
players in the
[Music]
world it's been a fun start to the event
but now the fun is over and the players
are ready to put on their game faces and
begin the
[Music]
competition
the question on Twitter from
damass uh I should not have pronounced
that uh that was a bit of a trap
yeah there
aend one tank in a
City St Louis is the stop but nonstop
fun so much fun for your family infinity
plus a ton there's museums full of Art
and super fun slides upside down
concrete twisty turny rides Houses full
of magic some with butterflies Gardens
growing
flowers Louis
isop fun so f for your family Infinity a
t healthc care in America is changing
evolving and we're helping lead the
transformation Ascension is made up of
Physicians and other caregivers called
to deliver compassionate personalized
care for all as one of the largest
providers of care in the country our
patients benefit from collaboration
between hospitals medical practices and
Healthcare innovators Nationwide
ascension's faith-based Heritage means
we have a moral obligation to serve
everyone especially those who are
struggling last year we provided almost
$2 billion in care for people living in
poverty and for programs to help them
whether it's in a hospital a
neighborhood CL Clinic a senior living
facility or at home ascensions care
providers value every aspect of our
patients lives and health we listen with
respect to ensure every person we serve
gets the right care for them
personalized compassionate that's
Ascension
[Music]
n
a
[Music]
I
w
[Music]
o
he
[Music]
for
well welcome back to round three now of
the Paris Grand chest tour so the final
round of day one the final round of day
one it's been absolutely cracking it up
Way Beyond Way Beyond what I expected
you know I didn't expect let's take a
look at the standing yeah let's recap on
that so in the lead of course is Wesley
so with a perfect four out of four
chasing him is Magnus Carlson mvl
wrestling TOA on three points and uh on
50% Hikaru Alex G Guk Serge karakin all
on two and
uh and uh yeah let's let's look at the
pairings for round three let's see if
there are
any oh wow cracking matchup there
between Magnus and the ls second place
big game Fabiano versus Hikaru now
remember in staga Fabiana managed to
defeat Kari in a stunning game totally
but look at Fabby he's got a Target on
his back having lost two as does etan
vro in a big game uh grishik Wesley so
grishik also in second place looking to
take down the tournament leader with
white of course and I know Wesley has
been a little bit on the lucky side as
well a lot of
bit on the lucky side indeed and as
Maurice has mentioned time and time
again when Wesley does get a good lead a
good Head Start he's a tough man to
catch can he maintain his perfect score
we will see as play get started it's
difficult to say it's very early days
I'm telling you and it's been so
fast-paced we've just been jumping from
the games and dramatic moments and the
players have come to play The Players
definitely have come to play and they've
come to provide fireworks it seems we we
were a bit worried that they were
playing in a studio that there wouldn't
be any fireworks that they would be a
little bit more subdued well that has
been completely wrong exactly uh we I
noticed a trend especially uh with uh
Alexander grishuk as well as etti and
backro their clock management has simply
been awful yeah they're getting down
games it's points points yeah and this
man he had he had a win in his grasp in
round two and he just let it go it's
several times several times critical
moments and there you see
and the play is
underway well Fabby and Hikaru as you
just mentioned that Staffing last round
and it was so key in that candidat guys
I think we have an early candidate for
uh the game of the day of the round we
have Magnus Carlson versus vasher lra
and we've seen a sicilian on the board
once again when we see Sicilian we
expect it to be explosive but it's
Magnus it is B5 check and as you
mentioned it is Magnus and he decided to
play the tame Bishop E2 after E5 Knight
F3 H3 Castle uh Castle's on the same
side and uh the plays not going to be
that Dynamic but there's still a lot of
uh a lot of strategical Concepts into
play especially related to this this
Square on D5 and uh let's check
out your heart back verus to off what do
we
have we have well an opening we both
like oh we do indeed and uh the two
knights uh line takes Knight F6 and how
often have we seen oops KN bd7 and the
smothered mate we always get like to get
in those smothered mates instead we had
an immediate trade of knights uh night
takes Queen takes I suspect Knight F6
Knight D7 has been played let's see I
was really curious about this Wesley so
game okay there we have Magnus Carlson
in a stayed Sicilian if you ever can
call a sicilian estate one and one of
the most popular openings on tour the
Joko piano being essay between Sergey
andov they're very good friends in fact
I think they even work together so it'll
be interesting to see whether they just
take it easy you know it's the final
round take it easy prepare prepare for a
day two and let's just see how the
opening clash between uh Fabiano and
Hikaru
developed played this exact same
position uh maybe two months ago against
grandm rombaldi from Italy in this
position I did play Knight A3 I'm not
sure if yes Hikaru played Knight B6 and
I followed with Knight E5 after which
Knight G4 came quite unexpected for me
and and uh taking on G4 is not that good
because after take take take on G black
can actually play castle and this is a
very very dangerous position for white
if you take uh The Exchange you're going
to have huge problems on the light
squares if you don't take the exchange
I'm going to go Rook B8 and I'm going to
uh exert a lot of pressure on this B
Pawn Queen D7 Knight A4 in in future end
games and so from what I see Fabiano did
something else after Knight B6 he took
directly on C4 now if you take Queen a
queen A4 I recapture my knight uh
instead black played Castle Knight A5
and uh White still has a slight Edge
though I think uh black is is well uh he
doing quite well all right good good
point and I just bringing up that game
uh between grishuk and Wesley so let's
take it from the top and ghook is one of
those players who likes to play the
London system he really introduces and
popularize Bishop F4 I started seeing
some of his colleagues picking up on
this second move Bishop F4 and the
players quickly have reached this
position D takes D takes C5 is a little
bit I think that's still standard a
little bit but this one Bishop takes F4
that's a little bit surprising to me
usually Bishop takes C5 I would have
thought was the prayer book Queen Queen
A5 looking to recapture the pawn and now
uh White's idea is to control the D4 and
E5 squares as long as he can maintain
this these control of these squares it
really limits the power of the bishop on
C8 for example Knight D7 Queen takes
Knight here Queen here uh D6 G3 and uh
if you're not breaking with E5 saddling
yourself with an isolated D Pawn this
bishop on uh C8 doesn't see the light of
day for quite some time yes so
intriguing uh game going on here between
our I would say tournament leaders at
the moment it's still very very early of
course and we're going to be bringing
you three days of Rapid chess as we
start the first leg of the grand chess
tour three rounds a day and they the
players are on the third and final round
yes where would you like to go uh um
let's take magnet Magus Magnus is he up
top or where is Magnus let me just uh go
through we have
eten that was that game and this one
looks like it this one looks like it so
Magnus Carlson uh as Christian was
mentioning this is a very um well-known
way of meeting the nidorf
it's typically positional uh channels
very safe play by white white limits uh
Black's counterattacking possibilities
but does he limit his own chances of
winning what's your take Christian uh
well I definitely like what Magnus did
he diffusing the nidorf basically
there's no Dynamics in the board there's
only one important Square in the board
and that is d square on D5 I'm going to
play Queen D3 Castle put my Rook on the
D file and then Knight E3 Knight D5 in
my opinion these type of positions uh
White plays for two results a draw or a
win so uh we'll see if vasher will be
able to hold the drw but vasher cannot
win this game all right and let's go to
Ma and haris
Maurice and it's important what you just
said Christian about Vash not being able
to win this game remember last year that
this tournament was four days long not
five it was only after the play players
had played Four rapid games and five
rapid games in one day did they realize
just how tiring it was to be playing all
those games so we talked about it
everyone had a big discussion and said
you know what give the players a break
and only make it three games a day and
that way you can do it all in three days
and it was wonderful that the organizers
obliged and allow that to happen that
gives you a little a chance to be more
strategic and it's not just a physical
drain on the players and that means that
in the last round you're going to see
players like like last round of today
they're going to go for the win but
they're not necessarily going to have to
go all the way for the win because
they're fresh they're rested they're
strategic and they're not just falling
on their faces from fatigue this
position is that kind of position hold
him down and hit him squeeze hold and
squeeze maybe hit him hold and squeeze
some more hit him some more don't just
go all out and try to beat him up and
you know Maxim Vash lra loves those kind
of positions they're a wild and crazy
where he gets his punches too you look
at a game for example fabbi and Naka
another type of let's just get a little
something there's not much for white a
little bit of space I got some space
lock you down and I'll see how I'm going
to build this position against you when
you don't have much to do that's what
Fabiano wants to do here and he needs to
do it quickly because the time control
has been a problem for him and he's been
blundering and lost his first two games
as a result another game it's all about
the space for white is this one kakin
versus mov this one is space why just
wants to control the game and it seems
like that's what's happening in each one
of these games in this round that white
is being able to get just that edge and
now play Just positional squeeze don't
let black get wild counterplay as he has
done so far so expect the players to be
very solid they've after this round they
get to go back to the hotel and rest
spend the afternoon before playing at 2
p p.m. London time tomorrow so they'll
have plenty of time to recharge their
batteries thank you Maurice let's just
take a look at our current
format as round three is underway and
there here we have have it so just a
quick reminder it's a nine round robin
where the players all play each other
and there will be three games per day
three three rounds per day with the
unusual time control of 25 minutes plus
10c DeLay So no added time at all and
then of course in the blitz they'll be
playing nine round nine games of Blitz
for two days so 18 games of Blitz in
total each Blitz game is worth one
point uh the rapid games are each worth
two points and in the blitz it's 5
minutes per
player 3 second delay what we call the
brunstein delay but we have breaking
news uh Christian uh between Magnus and
mvl holy cow yes what happened what
happen was supposed to be sitting on it
Maurice was talking about hold and
squeeze I was talk about hold and
squeeze strategical Concepts Square on
D5 Magnus just decided to throw it all
out of the window he played the move A5
B5 Knight to B6 Knight takes to
E4 very very interesting move after
Knight takes C4 Bishop takes C4 Knight
takes A8 Queen takes 8 this hasn't been
played on the board yet Magnus is still
pondering his uh decision after Knight
takes C4 but potentially this could uh
be on the board and this is a another
crazy position sacrifices all over the
board so um very very interesting game
but okay The Exchange uh MBL has
sacrificed the exchange for the
imbalance of a very powerful bishop and
pawn but as Sicilian players know you
get those two connected pass Pawns in
the center life could be good and you
were saying there's only two results uh
will make differ there could be three
results here and show us the current
position if you will uh yes this is I've
seen some action this is the current
position so um okay white took on e4
Bishop takes E4 and now I'm not really
sure if he has any other option but to
take the Rook on A8 uh the computer is
actually offering this enterprising
strategical move C4
W very very interesting if you take on
C4 I'm going to
go Queen to A4 check King to f8 and now
take the RO and now I'm just going to
take your Pawn I this is what I was
talking about strategical Concepts we're
we're once again going to have uh most
probably opposite opposite color Bishops
or we're going to have a good knight uh
against a bad Bishop in case of an
exchange after Bishop D5 Bishop takes D5
Knight takes D5 that's enough
compensation for the pawn wow C2 C4 is
really a visual move I didn't expect
that at all I didn't see that I I just
was focused on The Rook I had exactly
give me The Rook yeah C4 that's high
high futin move boy A5 no I liked your
approach uh Christian which was Queen D3
keep it under control right and A5 just
you know the dam has burst after this
Knight takes E4 Knight takes E4 Bishop
takes E4 um I was trying to limit the
damage with Knight takes A8 and get that
material imbalance of being an change
for a pawn but this move C2 C4 that's
a well say I I since you're going to
take on B5 and you want to how about
castles I
mean you played C4 congrat congrats um
what you got I mean you got to take the
Rook haven't you after C4 I mean and if
I were to just yeah yeah take the rook
and go Bishop F3 well I'm not quite sure
how then why you why
that was the computer exactly exactly
you don't have to explain the computers
moves nobody understands that it's alien
alien yeah I am assuming that yes you
play F3 because this diagonal is just so
powerful you want to neutralize it to
need to blunt that one boy this is super
sharp let's go to let check with Maurice
Maurice hang on yes indeed and I
misspoke earlier saying we were in
London I'm looking forward to that
tournament at the end of the year but
this one is still going on and yes
Christian you're right black realized
hey he's about to get squeezed in all
these games and players are breaking out
we just saw mvl do it against Magnus
Carlson now we see Karu nakamura's turn
you take a look at a position like this
it looked quite quiet it looks like
black needs to make some kind of
developing move maybe bishop F5 which
cannot yet be played so he should be
Queen C7 look to play B6 he's might have
to worry about E4 but not yet so that
would be solid Queen C7 maybe well how
about the move C5 the move that doesn't
look like it can be played because that
pawn is covered twice now the engine is
not a big fan of this move but it's a
it's a sacrifice clearly you cannot take
with this Pawn because you're hanging
your knight on A5 so that would just be
terrible but what if you take with this
Pawn well now you open up the long
diagonal for this bishop and black can
play the move Knight to E4 and look at
that C3 Square as these Knights threaten
to hop onto that square and definitely
cause some damage at least some
counterplay Nakamura playing this move
move surprising Fabby with a move it
looked like he had everything under
control but suddenly C5 is on the board
players with black they don't like to be
sat on and clearly mvl and Nakamura got
the same memo go for the counterplay
thank mauce what a visual move C6 C5 I
mean you hit with that because you got
your pawns on B4 D4 you're stopping it
but he did it anyway Christian what do
you got for us well I have another
visual move which hasn't been played yet
on the board in the position in the game
between uh Magnus Carson and vasher lra
instead of our move C4 Magnus decided to
play played safe he played Bishop to F3
Bishop takes F3 Queen takes F3
controlling the light squares Rook Rook
A7 C4 now and guess what another visual
move
D5 I'm opening up my Bishop I'm
preparing Bishop B4 to uh to uh upset
this white king and now if you play
Knight takes D5 I'm going to take this
Pawn on C4 and this is not what you want
uh what you want to see as white because
the knights need outposts this Knight
doesn't have any Outpost he's a nice
Knight but he's going to be relocated
after Rook D7 so after D5 probably the
best move would actually be to Castle
everything based on the initiative B
takes C4 and now once again we're not
taking the pawn on D5 we're playing Rook
to
D1 crazy Mad Madness uh Madness on the
board one once again um but D5 is a very
very difficult move to see so I'm not
sure if vashir has has the time to see
that to calculate all of the nuances I
love it D I love D5 and also I love
why's continuation you know just IGN
just ignore it thank you very much going
to Castle one of the things you really
do see amongst these elite players they
really don't like being on the back foot
uh they love the initiative and this
idea of white to sacrifice upon and get
firmly rooted control of the D5 Square
was magnus's idea and he's played D he
oh that's a
beauty I love body language it's like
there you go there you go there you go
have some fun with this one and boy and
we're seeing it also in this game of
Hikaru uh Fabiano I mean C5 really comes
out of the blue and it almost seems like
he's uh he's angry at
Magnus right how dare you D5 yes you you
how dare how dare you try to squeeze me
like that exactly I'm going to play D5
challenge oh my goodness so all the
players are really really bringing great
play to this uh opening stage of the
grand chest I tell you if they keep up
the space for the next four days it's
going to be we're yeah it's going to be
a chess Bear's dream isn't it exactly
exactly and there you had some nice
webcam shots of the yes world champion
Magnus Carlson essaying this move D5 and
definitely MBL look satisfied that's a
gorgeous move to play do you think he's
seen
castles sorry the the response just
Castle I think maybe he he's he's
banking on because obviously when you
play D5 you calculate what would happen
if they capture the pawn that would of
like the first and and then you probably
get that satisfactory boom play it
somehow you know you don't you you don't
evaluate the position of castles right
you just assume it's going to be good
yeah yeah what I I've got it
undercovered but as You' seen it is
actually quite tricky you know castles
and then the Rook coming to
D and black is black is struggling a
little bit in terms of initiative in
terms of time because the deor probably
will fall so interesting uh I I I love
what the players are doing I mean yeah
all three results possible you're not
just sitting back and saying okay you
know you got some tiny Edge squeeze me
if you can no no no no it's
all breakthroughs yeah Okay so we've got
wonderful games going on here let's just
check in with some of the other games uh
but first we'll go to Paris with
Maurice well looking very happy and
pleased with himself as mvl in this
situation and Roman you have played with
him many times and you seen this look on
his face before yeah well I mean um well
when yeah he obviously very happy with
his move D5 and uh I already saw him
well when he plays this kind of uh
surprising mov is in general well he
always has this attitude that then is
trying to keep as calm as possible but
you can see that he's very happy so I
recognize this uh very well when he
played D5 so you were telling us a story
earlier about some some game that you
were sitting next to him when he he made
this move King F3 yeah actually probably
will be laughing when he will listen to
me saying this story but yeah once he
had some uh he had some game uh when he
had the Knight Hing on on D3 okay the
opponent was rning Rog takes D3 and he
played some move King F3 and if Rog
takes D3 it would be king E2 trapping
The Rook in amending and it was next to
him and he was having the same attitude
you know trying to so okay I find it
quite funny of course this uh well of
course he's happy with himself as a
spectacular line but even more
interesting now that after D5 was played
Magnus looked a little befuddled in the
position but he did take on B5 allowing
Bishop to B4 check and now his King is
in the middle of the board after King to
E2 and this board is clearly on fire
right now the D5 Pawn is going to drop
what kind of compensation do you think
Magnus has it looks like Magnus should
be able to win his Pawn back at the
moment actually the it's six pawns
against six and he's going to get the D
Pawn as black gets the B Pawn well I'm
going say computer wants to Castle I see
uh after ab5 Knight D5 this should be
yeah this should be much better for
white I guess or not Bishop A5 B4 Bishop
B6 yeah computer is holding but uh I
would not be so confident uh although
maybe maybe it works the bishop has a
very nice Square on D4 so okay if I if
you can play AB is one thing if computer
says Castle is also good then probably
there is no room for for a mistake here
yeah spectacular very visual move D5
with mvl showing that he certainly
enjoys himself whenever he plays a great
move
thank you gentlemen but boy uh isn't mag
taking huge risks by putting his King in
the middle of the board King well it
goes against everything we've ever been
taught absolutely I mean our coaches
would be jumping up and down after this
m too I i' want to get my king out of do
right away I would go castles as well me
I guess Rook D1 and then he can a rook
D1 or Knight takes D5 D5 takes on A6 I
don't know what Magnus has in mind but
but it takes it's two moves from safety
so if we calm ourselves down you know
after after Knight takes D5 and then
Rook goes to D1 King can then yeah it
takes some tempy Knight takes D5 but
you're walking into E4 too so Knight
takes D5 is not a bet of roses for white
after
E4 so many things are going on and the
king and the center I've always been
told although I've transgressed let me
be the first to say you know like I've
taking King walks that I should not have
Christian your take that's crazy is M
world champion Magnus Carlson taking so
much risk what well Magnus Carlson is
definitely taking some risks but it
seems like absolutely every player is
enjoying taking some risks in the first
couple of rounds uh Nakamura for example
in this position as Maurice mentioned he
played the visual C5 D takes C5 Fabiano
immediately grabbed the pawn Knight E4
and now Fabiano found the very very nice
and precise move Knight to G5 now if you
take on a on A1 I'm going to take Knight
take C4 and because of this bishop on G2
extremely powerful Bishop coupled with
the action of the Knight on A5 is going
to paralyze uh the queen side white has
a lot a lot of initiative for the
exchange instead of that Nakamura played
Knight to C3 this is already uh looking
not so good for black because after for
example a move a simple move such as
Queen C2 uh what are you going to do how
are you going to continue I'm just
threatening to play Bishop B2 Rook C1
and and and the position seems to be
completely dominating for white and
continue the line Knight takes E2 check
takes E2 Tak Bishop takes a one um it's
an
exchange not anymore oh not anymore the
dou attack we're not friends anymore
Christian I Queen A2 that's a lovely is
right you know if if white is allowed us
to get Bishop B2 Rook D1 this is Happy
Days of course a pawn to the good so did
hearu when he Ed C5 overlook this nice
move Knight G5 Fabiano did play Queen C2
Hikaru is pondering his next decision
but uh it's not an easy one he's he's in
deep deep trouble he's burned his
Bridges no most definitely with the move
C5 he has to show compensation was
correct just to grab the Rook earlier
and that that compensation is is fading
away really really quickly well I'm
sorry to say if there's no Knight takes
E2 check I don't get it for no that's
what I'm saying you should have just
grab the Rook you're going to have to
play Bishop F5 Bishop
F5 oo and now the trick is if if I go E4
you can actually take back on e4 but
even this is not uh not very good for
black after
nightx
B7
wow okay this is really this these are
some very complexations you better be
calculating you got to have how does uh
a good night
sleep absolutely and a lot of confidence
oh my goodness oh my goodness this is
one of the other things that I find so
extraordinary about the top elite
players today they've done so much work
with their engines and computers that
they calculate deep lines very very
quickly we used to uh be in awe uh vishy
a non a five-time world champion and his
calculating abilities long before the
engine came and now these guys today
they've they've trained themselves their
calculation is remarkable and just in
that line that Christian was showing I
mean I I'd be spending half my time just
counting the pieces in the ponds after
each
after every line you stop and say okay
what was this what's the score what's
the score we actually have a move played
I think he played B6 yes Nakamura played
the move
B6 which is actually quite a quite a
smart move because you're asking white
what are you going to do with this uh
Knight on A4 I'm trying to get some sort
of uh initiative and I'm trying to
relocate this knight from F5 very very
powerful knight white played Knight C6
and after Queen C 7 for example I can
play I have to play actually the move
Bishop to B2 to preserve all my
advantage um if you take on C6 yes sir
cuz I I'm just going to take on uh C3
and you're pinned the Knight on D5 is
pinned um very very difficult moves from
both sides but uh if Fabiano manages to
find the right continuation he's going
to be uh winning this game yep wow and
I'm just looking at another another game
that uh etan bakro versus vessel Toof
I'm looking at this bishop on H6 and
that is really a pathetic Bishop that is
a the Rick the Rick is on uh the Rick is
on PR on G6 well you kind of please take
my Rook Bishop takes G6 King takes G6
and this bishop on H6 will need a
Perpetual Defender for the rest of the
game The Rook on H1 will be stuck and
vessel and topof will be very pleased
with the outcome of this position
uh let me just check in on the game of
Magnus Carlson for a moment and
interestingly uh the boys in Paris uh
correctly predicted I was expecting
after this move Bishop B4 check castles
at once Bishop takes A5 and B4 just as
uh Edward and uh Maurice yes well I
think uh the body language of vashir the
satisfying uh move he made when he
played D5
definitely impacted Carlson who in this
position has to find very very precise
Moves In order to make a draw Knight
takes B6 Queen Tak he didn't play it by
the way he play Rook takes A7 he play
yes he played Rook takes A7 at once okay
and then I'm going to retreat my Bishop
to B8 to B8 to to B8 the problem is yes
cuz of Rook A8 yes if you Retreat the
bishop here then I to D4 to D4 to D4 ah
to D yes correct d Bish a little bit
better but the same problem remains Rook
to A8 Queen takes A8 and now Knight C6
Knight I was only looking
at these are not uh these are not
beginner players
Yer they're definitely not I am yes
vasher is um is well known for his
tactics the same for Magnus so in this
position Bishop B8 Bishop B8 seems like
the normal move forced move forced move
yes um and I'm not sure okay you're
going to play Rook A5 I'm going to play
castle you're going to take this Pawn
but your king is still still very very
uh fragile so uh with the bishop on the
board the Queen The Rook um this might
turn quite uh quite uh quite an
interesting game also I'm a little bit
worried that the Knight on D5 while it
look looks very good it doesn't actually
have a not support it exactly we always
say that the KN increases in strength
the greater it support as Christian said
it's not a night natural Outpost without
a Pawn on e4 or Pawn on C4 the Knight
needs uh constant protection this move
B7 B6 by the way that Hikaru encored uh
arguably it's the best move in the
position but this Knight on C6 really
looks visual Queen D7 was played E4
and to the wind after E4 uh hi Caro said
okay Bishop A6 and we have got complete
mess on our hands Christian how do you
evaluate this is completely winning in
this completely winning in this position
because of the straightforward captures
I'm just going to take the Knight what
are you going to do next if you take on
F1 then I'm just simply going to take uh
with the King defending the D5 PA you
cannot take back for example if you go
here I take Knight takes D5 Bishop takes
D5 now you cannot retake on D5 because
of Knight D7 Fork so let's say you go
eat this Rook now I'm just going to play
Queen C4 I have how many pieces one two
three pieces for two Rooks a very very
unusual imbalance material imbalance um
but the problem is I have also this Pawn
on C5 who's going to be well on his uh
promoting uh uh Square anytime soon so
the F7 porn as well I'm a little bit
also also the F7 Point absolutely so
after he takes D5 Knight E2 is probably
going to have to be played King H1
Bishop takes A1 uh but after Rook E1
with this powerful Center this
uncoordinated pleas pieces of blacks uh
this doesn't look appealing for uh for
him nice thank you very much Christian
that was beautiful pie of work
absolutely wonderful back to Paris and
Maurice yes and one thing you notice
about strong players like I said with
the black pieces you're getting squeezed
if you're playing an over the board game
you got a lot of time on your clock you
probably are very careful how you
calculate your counterplay you don't
want to play a move for example like
what happened in the game with Hikaru
like C5 if you haven't really well
worked it out and instead you might play
something solid and slowly develop your
game but in Rapid they take chances you
don't want to just be sitting there
getting squashed so you take some
chances and sacrifice some things here
Vaseline topalov it looks like his
position is not so bad there's some
space for white everything looks okay
and here he decided to play the move
Rook to G6 and now after Bishop to D3
sacrific The Exchange suddenly with
Bishop takes E4 he not something You'
think he had to do but he did it because
he wants to have enterprising play
despite the fact that he's going to go
down a little bit of material this is
typical topalov well this is typical
topalov and this is probably also the
best move because well this
position I mean it is quite decent for
black but he should do something like R
G6 because otherwise I may play well I
may put some pressure on the D5 Pawn or
I may play any anyway Bishop D3 next
throughing Bishop H7 so I think Rook G6
is just very wise because well it's an
action sacrifice but you get one pound
and you get rid of the bishop there so I
think it is simply the best move here
and he played it Rook G6 Rook to G6
Bishop to D3 Bishop takes G4 takes and
King takes and now this bishop finds
himself buried in the position he is
down in exchange right now for a pawn is
toala but how this bishop ever gets into
the game is anybody's guess backro now
feels like must feel like I might lose
this one too after losing two two games
and he didn't play so badly yeah I mean
well this is apparently still about
equal uh well the computer doesn't mind
just holding this bishop on H6 and he
claims that if black tries to do
something then he going to be worse I
guess this is why he claims uh the
position is completely equal but of
course when you're zero out of two it's
not so pleasant to have this bishop on
H6 and the position is completely
different than the one it was after 20
moves when white was or much better um
now there is no Bishop PA and black is
very solid is very active he has his
pieces perfectly placed so well I would
not be surprised if fan would lose one
more very tough day at the office for
the Frenchmen to lose three games in one
day that just would not fly be very
difficult of course to come back
tomorrow but youve got to play all the
games so some suffering going on we'll
see whether not he's able to save the
pride of France in this game and make
maybe at least a draw thank you very
much for that Maurice well fire on the
board all the games look at this game
between Rish and Wesley we mentioned
when we left it that uh White's idea was
very straightforward he wanted to keep
control of the dark squares of D4 and E5
so that this
bishop remains passive and uh Wesley was
having none of that after maybe the
premature G5 he got his chance to play
the move E6 E5 talk about breakthrough
pawn moves in all the games right is a
theme with the round totally and E5
opens up the bishop well the whole point
is that Queen takes E5 if you if you
grab the bait you've got an issue on
you're going to have to get sacrifice
the queen now yes because Unfortunately
The Rook is hanging but how do I unpin
myself right and oh yeah you got no
choice The Rook on C4 uh the night's not
going anywhere and oh by the way whites
King is a little drafty yeah whites King
is a little bit drafty Let's uh let's
have a look at what we anticipate will
be a four sequence and our tournament
leader Wesley so
may have a perfect day at the office if
etn is having a bad day this looks like
black is in the driver seat Christian
Christian what do you see absolutely
black is in the driver's seat because of
a white blunder in this position G5 was
a horrendous mistake why would you do G5
instead of that you should have played
Queen to E5 keep control over the dark
squares and then you're going to play G5
obviously Guk uh missed this interesting
idea of E5 and right now is black who is
uh who is uh leading after Queen takes
E5 which is forced Rook to E8 Queen to
E8 Bishop E8 Rook E8 King to
H7 with a naked King like this uh and
the Queens on the board uh this doesn't
look good for uh for white but let's
look at this game between Magnus Carlson
and vashir the way the way Magnus is
playing at the moment it reminds me of
his old self in this position after
Bishop Bishop B8 he played the move
Queen D3 Castle normal move Queen takes
B5 and in this position uh vashir was
just a little bit too slow he should
have play the move Queen H4 activate the
queen attack the pawn on H2 Queen to E4
comes the king is a little bit
endangered he the position is still very
balanced but black shouldn't have any
problems holding instead of that he
played the move E4 allowing white to
play G3 Bishop E5 Rook to D1 Now You See
white is engaging in a light Square
strategy he's placing all his pieces on
the light squares and as long as he
manages to hide his King on G2 then he's
going to be able to push his B Pawn and
black is going to have huge difficulties
defending against that after Queen G5
King F1
F5 after Queen E2 B5 I'm not really sure
if black has uh any sort of initiative
so this definitely doesn't look good uh
for vashir Magnus seems to have found
his old self very confident wow that a
subtle subtle shift because I like
Black's position what he was doing
and that very natural just yeah but
Queen H4 also looked very natural queen4
definitely I would have been there get
the bits out get the bits out Queen
would have been there attack H2 yeah for
sure right we would have now uh and now
the advantage uh with the world champion
and Christian uh after this uh position
the final position that you did reach uh
what should MV be doing uh he's got to
be careful that knight7 check played F5
he's just trying to play F4 he's trying
to open up uh the position towards the
white king uh try to get some sort of
counterplay because if we're going to
play a strategic game black is going to
be in trouble so white in this position
has to play the move Queen E2 Y and
let's say well the problem with Queen E2
is that it doesn't allow the move F4
because now I can just simply catch uh
catch this Pawn so instead of that after
queen2 you have to play something like
Bishop to D6 which doesn't seem like a
very natural move to me and uh sorry
what was wrong with F4 again F4 Queen
takes C4 I take on you take on G3 I
would ass this is what you want to do
yes yes I'm going to continue taking
there's a check on the problem is well
whichever piece you used to take on G3
you're going to allow me to play the
move uh Knight E7 and that's going the
combination between the queen and the
Knight is very very potent and uh this
is exactly what Magnus is banking on
right now that's a good point that is
that's evil not nice that's that's
devilish that's that's what chess is all
about parent tries to do something and
you're go nothing sweet so that means
that the immediate F4 has to you can't
do it you got to prepare it yeah somehow
Bishop D6 is actually the only move to
keep the balance and uh even so after
that I mean from from a visual
perspective this this doesn't look good
for black
I think we have a Carana game from
Maurice yes let's go to Paris let's go
to
Paris well my partner in crime here has
proven himself to be a great tactician
as we analyze a lot of variations here
and ROM you found a sweet line here I'd
like you to share with the audience uh
the position right now Bishop to B2
although Queen C4 seemed like more of a
move but this line is very nice Bishop
to B2 and uh Bishop B2 E6 Bishop F3
takes takes and now the tactic you
pointed out yeah I mean white wants to
play Knight E4 so it looks like the only
move for black should be F5 but it is
unfortunate F6 sorry and it is
unfortunately losing in because of
Knight E6 Queen E6 Bishop D5 Queen E5
and Knight D7 check so I think if black
cannot play F6 then he uh Oly lost uh so
it looks like all the tactics are
working for white this is extremely
impressive uh how the white pieces are
working here and Bishop B2 well of
course computer was pointing Queen C4
here with similar ideas that after E6
you can go Knight E6 but this move
Bishop B2 I think is very impressive and
it is well just getting rid of this uh
Bishop that is the best black pieces the
best black piece to well to to to defend
the position and then looks like black
is Oly lost because after well Bishop A1
Bishop B2 take take also H6 is losing
because there is another sacrifice and
then knight5 check come in in the end
well maybe the no maybe the other one
maybe let's play that out just in case
after Rook to take check and uh well
another Fork this time on E5 excuse us
let's just get that going so the tactics
are scintillating Fabian Carana it looks
like he's had his countryman's number he
played a win just recently in Norway
upsetting nakamura's tournament and of
course we saw that fabulous when he had
in London when again Bishops and knights
were crawling all over Nakamura with
that amazing Queen sacrifice that he
cooked up so Fabby getting back in the
winner circle it seems
all is not finished just yet we know
anything could happen in Rapid actually
didn't play Bishop
F3 um he took he took on A1 that's a big
development he said should also be very
strong should be strong but not the same
though because he doesn't get if he was
trying to get along this diagonal of
course this move F6 is coming very fast
and is a reputation so that's not going
to work right
now we expected to see that but now he's
might have mucked it up a little bit uh
sorry takes let's let's go forward takes
no let's go back here he played uh he
played takes takes and 95 and queen to
E7 also looks completely winning I mean
well KN yes Knight G4 computer is
suggesting uh did he have to go to E7
but now looks probably not Queen F5 is
probably more logical but uh yeah
computer just say taken Knight D7 and
also the C pwn is coming well this
should be completely winning for white
also maybe Queen F5 is not for maybe I
can play Queen C3 or something have to
see um okay so Fab's human but he's
found some human strong moves that still
look like they're going to seal the deal
but I must say that looks like a you
know find the win you a diagram tactical
diagram there's got to be a win you have
to feel sorry for hikaro because if it's
not the kingside attack that's going to
finish him it's going to be that se porn
yeah that's bad news and and worse these
minor pieces are like honeybees
swarming yeah with the Rook on a A8 out
of out of the out of uh play and if you
get F6 then no white white white pieces
are partying all over the board uh looks
really really powerful Christian guys we
have some uh interesting developments in
the game between Magnus Carlson and
vasher lra as expected vasher didn't
manage to hold the position and right
now he's completely lost oh he
sacrificed let's see what happened so
oh we have a result in it's over it's
over after queen queen E2 very precise
move my by
Magnus King h8 F4 whoa you missed F4
okay so vashir missed a simple fork and
after that he was just forced uh to
sacrifice his whole Army to try to get
something but nothing happened Magnus
defended accurately Knight F4 Knight G6
I'm taking absolutely everything away
from you and after I think Knight F4 he
played no Knight H4 um that's vashir was
forced to resign couple of moves later
yes Magus finding his form scary move
scary news for it is scary news expected
we we knew that he was playing
exceptionally great chess out of Blitz
and Rapid yes was the classical that was
the classical has been some hiccups
going on but his he's looking really
really good and these
backtack rounds uh the world champion is
going to be very pleased I not I'm sure
he's going to want to be
interviewed with these two what else
have you got first US
Christian we have a game between kakin a
player we haven't focused a lot on and
mamed are one of my favorites in this
position we know that the combination
between the queen and the knight in
general is better than the queen and the
bishop the problem in this position is
that the Knight on G one doesn't really
have a good placement if you go on F3
then I'm just going to continue playing
H5 G4 take this Knight away and my king
is very very protected your king is not
instead of that white played B5 a takes
B5 Queen takes B5 trying to open up the
line towards the B7 pawn and try to
activate uh his Queen the problem is
whenever he lives with a queen from this
side this queen can come into play and
the King might be in trouble and this is
exactly what happened Queen E5 Knight F3
Queen A1 King E2 Queen A2 King F1 and
now mamedov is still thinking but if he
decides to repeat the moves and then
make this move Queen C1 I think uh he's
going to have the advantage well we
don't know if he's going to see that he
might be afraid that the queen on B5 is
too active and he might go for the
Perpetual with Queen A1 queen queen A2
but if he decides to play for a win then
uh Queen C1 would be very very good for
him he thank you Christian and things
have blown up in the game between
Alexander Gish hook and Wesley so Gish
hook recognizing that he was going to
have to give up his Queen he started the
sequence with the move B4 takes A5 Queen
E5 versus the immediate Queen E5 and
Wesley quickly went for the line that he
captures the queen and after this move
Rook E4 uh Wesley said okay gift me this
pawn and you don't have time for Knight
B5 there's a Queen A1 check the Rook on
e4 is hanging and Sasha G4 check W and
we've got a big big time disparity as
it's been the case throughout the the G
so we've seen some poor manage time
management by most 50 seconds 50 can I
can I replace Guk as one of my favorit
yes I'm also thinking the guy is giving
us a heart attack he's giving himself a
heart attack every single game I mean I
know that's uh his usual style but it
doesn't work when you when you're
playing with with delay when you're
playing with increment is a completely
different ball game okay but has uh
gisher no he after King takes G6 The
Rook came to the Rook went check Knight
takes he can set up a fortress that's
what I was trying to figure out but I
suspect with the hanging white pieces
and unfortunately just the weakness of
White's King it shouldn't
be oh that's a little bit surprised he
took oh yes he's picking up the pawn on
G4 yeah Wesley played very quickly
Wesley is playing the most precise moves
for D1 Queen D1 uh nice double attack
against The Rook on C2 as well as the
pawn on and I think A4 P will also drop
quickly quickly after Queen D1 did you
follow the sequence that the players
played I I was watching them and they
were playing quickly um it stopped at uh
after Knight D4 Queen takes G4 ah Knight
D4 Knight D4 Queen takes G4 King F1 yes
and now I think Wesley is considering
his options well I think he's going to
hang que Queen D1 Queen D1 G2 and round
up the PES yes but now you were
mentioning
fortresses
um I'm a little less keen on the
Fortress because it's two versus one I
mean if it had been horns on both sides
of the board I think it's the wrong
minor piece if you put a a white Bishop
uh pardon me a dark Square Bishop on D4
for the Knight your chances of Fortress
go way up the Knight and the Rook
against the queen I don't like this I
think that this as as world champion
Magnus Carlson famously said i' believe
I believe in fortresses yes you and I
don't believe in this one either no I
your take I actually think uh this might
be a fourth thress but white has to play
very very precisely in this position
after Queen A1 I have to bring my King
close to my other pieces so I will play
King F3 okay you go Queen takes A5
correct King to
E4 I'm going to connect these three
pieces together and then I'm just going
to start to push my pawn and I think
that's going to paralyze your queen and
allow me to get the blockade um your
take I I think we have a Maurice with
Magnus Carlson yes yes
that's we are with the current leader of
the tournament Magnus Carlson as he has
blown mvl off the board well maybe I'm
overstating the case because mvl did
blunder in one particular moment
magnus's opening was kind of solid no
issue going on and then you went for it
with this move A5 did you suspect that
he was going to sacrifice an exchange in
this exact position yeah I I thought so
uh and maybe I overestimated my my
chances a bit cuz it seems that that
black is um is all right there at least
I couldn't find anything and then the
game did go to a position here let's
just jump ahead uh right around here you
allowed your king to be on E2 everything
seemed to be stabilized until you got to
position right around here where you
were able to pick up this Pawn when you
got this Pawn back I mean you seem to
have sort of outplayed him just a little
bit but did you think now you had some
real winning chances not really I mean
but my my choice was basically just to
chop off the bishop on B6 and make a
draw or to play this unclear position
and I thought well why not try try and
play but I didn't particularly think I
was uh I was better I thought um I mean
if if I had like G3 and King G2 then I
would be better but with this unsafe
King and his potentially good Bishop I
um I mean it's going to take a long time
before my pass bone can amount to
anything and instead of that happening
we had this moment in the game where he
plays King to h8 you play Queen E2 it
looked like you were defending but of
course you had this not so subtle threat
were you shocked when you saw him move
his King over yeah of course um I mean I
didn't didn't even even you know think I
mean ma is very good tactically so you
don't expect these kinds of gifts but
yeah that's the way that's the way it is
after three rounds you're two and a half
points uh how do you feel about your
tournament right now um I I think it's
good um my actually you have five points
cuz you're getting double for the rapid
so it's even more important you're
winning the yeah I know I'm I'm playing
relatively well and uh my my opponents
are um are giving me chances so it's
it's excellent so far absolutely well
congratulations on today and get your
rest and we'll see you tomorrow thank
you world champion Magnus Carlson with
good reason to be smiling right now
leading the show although there's one
game left with Wesley so trying to bring
that point home but certainly in a good
position going into the second day it
certainly is in a good position and we
do have another result a top off backer
was ended in a
draw breathing
as his first points he didn't want to go
and three because that would have been
really terrible going into uh round two
uh take us to the position Christian if
you will between Fabby and Hikaru I
thought when we left it uh Fabby had the
game virtually wrapped up is that still
the case Fabby still has the game
wrapped up he's still winning but
he does have two minutes on the clock
against nakamura's 4 minutes so we know
when you read time pressure you are are
pra to make a lot of mistakes
um I will give it to him I think this
position is quite easy and I don't think
he's going to make any any big ones any
big mistakes uh I can just simply play
Knight G2 Knight to F4 try to put some
pressure on the G6 Pawn we realized that
the Knight on G5 is not actually
attacked so black cannot take on G5 uh
um he's still pondering his decision he
is under 1 minute and 30 seconds on the
clock this is not going to be a walk in
the park for Fabiano I think he uh he he
under under underplayed uh the position
a little bit mhm and in the position
that you have on the board Knight G2
isn't an intuitive move for me I would
would have thought more like Queen C5 uh
and playing Knight takes D5 Queen C is
is a good enough move good enough move
would be Black's reaction to that I
would play Queen C7 I see and um taking
the pawn
just Knight take D5 Knight takes D5
Queen takes C6 and queen takes A7 runs
into Rook D7 I see that now Queen takes
A7 Rook D7 and then you're going to lose
one of the pieces so I think you have to
play Queen takes C6 well Queen Tak C6
this end game is not that easy um
instead of that I think you have to take
on F6 first and this allows you to
maintain a decisive Advantage but look
there's a check on H1 very very
dangerous check whenever you're under
one minute you don't want your king out
in the open like that so this is a
little bit unnatural right now um Fabby
is making his life very very difficult
all right and the times again between
these two players at this moment it's
quite close it's one Fabby has 1 minute
and 15 seconds and hikara has 3 minutes
and 12 and remember they have 10-second
delay absolutely but I I like Knight G2
Knight G2 Knight F4 well that gets
really to the heart of the position I
actually thought the Knight on E3 was
well placed but when you put it on F4 is
really making a statement isn't it I
wanted to get the other I was thinking
of ways to get the a knight to F4 side
yes well Fabiano made the mistake oh uh
oh after Rook D6 what was his mistake
after Rook D6 he played the move the
natural move uh to be honest he played
the move C7 and uh in this position
after Rook C8 I'm not really sure how
you're going to defend the pawn on C7
what you can do though is go Knight to
F5 and try to go for the for the kill
after G takes F5 Queen takes F5 Queen
takes
C7 Bishop takes F6 Rook takes F6 Queen
H7 king
h8 queen h8 king E7 Queen G7 you're
hunting the king queen E8 Queen takes F6
and uh this is a very very very
difficult position to play for black
because your king is so exposed uh but
getting here is once again not very easy
for for Fabiano he has to find the move
Knight F5 very enterprising move and
then calculate precisely um the
consequences but if even in that final
position in the line if I were Hikaru I
would I would be feeling a bit a lot
more happy Rel a little bit I mean okay
you may lose it but the the the three
pieces versus the two Rook was just
horri
yeah uh and again uh despite the fact
that they are playing rapid chess uh the
calculations of these two players in
aaru most especially is really noted uh
really sharp but we have Maurice we have
Maurice with an interview with barro
who's just scored his first point so
over to you
Maurice yes we are with the Frenchman
eten bak and it must be very difficult
first of all to play on a home turf but
to play against these monsters in this
kind of event yes especially is that now
it started badly yeah first game already
I had okay good chance I almost saved
one very bad position I found good moves
but okay at the end he pushed me too
much so I lost round two it was the same
here with Wesley I had probably it was
completely winning here at some point
but okay I have uh also with a Time
control I'm not used to to this when I
go to like 30 20 seconds it's very
difficult yeah it was the bronen time
control you mean with the add time yes
yeah yeah there is only I mean there is
no bonus of time so no time to relax
during the game so do you feel like
you're hunted man like the players are
all after you as the lowest rated player
in this okay not really but um okay
after my start maybe who knows now even
in the round three I had quite good I
think but okay difficult three hours of
play against players not easy it's long
time what do you feel now after getting
a point at least being able to draw this
game against topalov do you feel going
into tomorrow you'll have settled out
the butterflies okay what whatever
happens I will play normal every round
so but I would have prefer to win but
draw is better than l so final question
any special pressure playing in France
does it does it matter okay pressure
because of the opponents not because of
the friends good answer all right well
we wish you luck in the rest of your
games thank you eten bakro definitely
keeping a jolly attitude about the day
so far we'll see what he does tomorrow
in the next few rounds thank you thank
you Maurice uh Christian big development
just happened Christian tell us all
about American All Star here well guess
who's not going to be jolly after this
day and that is Fabiano Carana because
he once again made a huge blunder in
time pressure in this position he found
Knight F5 G takes Queen takes F5 Queen
takes C7 but now instead of playing
Bishop takes F6 and going into the
variation we just analyzed he played the
move Queen H7 which it looks quite
natural unfortunately the king escapes
king f8 queen h8 king E7 Queen H7 King
E8 and I'm going to make my way on the
light squares Queen takes H5 King D7
Knight to F3 I think we have some extra
moves on the board yes the position is
still not easy this is not an easy
conversion for black because of his weak
King but he does have the advantage and
he also has 50 seconds more than Fabiano
this might be Fabiano's third loss in a
row oh my gosh and then you go from a
winning
position easily winning position as well
if if Fabian doesn't score it will be a
shock for him I mean his system will be
uh yo I'm not going to say broken
because he's such a he has such great
self-confidence but certainly shaken you
know that's really really harsh and we
he hasn't had a very successful year
though Fab Fabby he uh he didn't perform
very well in jalter he also didn't
become US champion so he's having a
little bit some wobbly moments right
yeah some wobbly moments I I mean and
certainly after these three games you
you got to feel a bit jinxed you got to
have this moment go come on yeah like
what do I have to do how many winning
positions do I need before I uh I score
one uh I like what uh Hikaru did very
much he stuck his centralized his Queen
on e4 pinning the Knight to uh in an
internal pin but Fabby they're on the
incre what's the seconds for it's a 18
18 seconds to 39 oh my goodness and he
just
blundered huge mistake Fabiano is
completely losing right now uh if if
Nakamura finds the right answer uh the
game is going to be over in a matter of
minutes and the right right answer is
Rook B6 which been played was played it
was played yes Rook killer move the
problem is the queen is overcharged you
have to defend the bishop on F6 and you
also have to defend against the entrance
on B3 and the attack on the on the F3
Knight so I think the best is something
like Queen A1 Rook B3 Queen D1 and now I
can just simply take on F3 take take
Rook takes F3 and I have Rook f8 at the
end so uh this is game over guys huge
huge turnar around
and the is over oh my my goodness wow
wow yes oh my
OMG I mean you know I I it's still so
fresh in my mind I think I I I'll I'll
never forget the 70 the street and I
can't recall Fabby losing three games in
a row I mean like this this and in this
every single game this is much better or
winning completely winning all three
games very simp it's a shocker simply a
shocker there's nothing else to to add
to that Fabiano must wake up um must go
back home look in the mirror give
himself a few slaps and and and come
back tomorrow with uh with vengeance so
we've heard Christian's advice go to the
what would you
say yeah well I remember I think I once
lost in my career three time three games
in a row and I really felt like
something had gone wrong the laws of
physics had changed they changed the
rules I mean I was really really really
rocked and I said okay I just have to
make a few draws and stop the bleeding
and I think that's what's uh necessary
exactly at this moment because it's not
the positions it's something else I mean
the positions have been brilliant and he
had I'm sure multiple wins in this game
uh other results what uh do you have for
us Christian well I think we have all
the games finished except one and no two
games still
going Guk who uh didn't managed to uh
create or did he is this uh is this a
blockade that's the question I'm going
to put my knight on G3 and then if I
manage to put my queen my Rook on E3
then all the pieces are going to be uh
quite compact uh around this these dark
squares of course King G5 King H4 is
always always a threat and uh with low
time control with only 11 seconds on the
on the clock Guk is still on the verge
of defeat um and we have another we have
a result it is over it is over he just
lost yes theyve just shaken shaken hands
and Wesley has given want a big smart
it's a draw it's a draw it's a draw oh
okay it was a draw ah there's um there
you have it uh this is the blockade you
just simply put your Rook on G3 and then
uh white white doesn't have any way of
of of making uh progress yeah well that
Knight on E2 turned out to be the
correct minor piece after all I thought
it was going to be a perfect day yeah
yeah it was very very good for West well
we have one more left guys yes we do
Shaq and Sergey m arov is on a winning
path here uh he found the way to avoid
the Perpetual in this
position I think yes H takes G4 H takes
G4 H takes G4 Queen D7 very precise
still G takes F3 and now a terrible
blunder by uh by karakin he took back on
G3 allowing black to retreat with the
Queen instead he should have played
Queen to G4 check just give the check
King H6 King H6 Queen takes F4 ah I
apologize King not way you can take a
not King
G6 Queen to G4 right draw yeah quite
easy draw instead of that he
played gf3 gf3 and then he allowed the
queen to get back into the game I I'm
not sure maybe maybe he was playing for
a win white was playing for a win uh
this doesn't seem
likely let's let let's go at the final
position because karakin has only 12
seconds left on the clock and
um he's simply losing he's losing
because the blockade is just gorgeous
he's just going to out Tempo and create
a zukan position thing you know you just
Waits with the bishop he just Waits and
white has to give the white King has to
take a step back
well a nice rebound win for for Shaq
after losing uh a tough one to Magnus
actually wow so are all of our results
in yes we have all the results and we're
going to have to take a look at our new
leader board as I think was I think we
do have a tie for First with mag Magnus
and wedley of course right with W five
out of a potential six yes that's right
we'll get that scoreboard to you shortly
and I think we're going to also have
some interviews with some of the players
we'll wait for Paris to get set up
I'm elated by the start I think that
this has really really been the the
players came clearly to Paris motivated
and they've been entertaining absolutely
they certainly have been entertaining us
with blunders and great high drama high
drama and uh time time time trouble this
delay has been very interesting actually
yeah the players have not yet adjusted I
think they'll do better by the I think
tomorrow we'll see perhaps grischuk and
uh ATN settle in and start performing a
little bit
better and tomorrow when will we be
starting because it's going to be rapid
it will be the same time it starts at
the same time so it will be our
show and here we are in St Louis so it's
6:50 a.m. local time here in St Louis
will the time be in Europe uh 12 2 2. 2
2 p.m have it
yes and uh we go to Maurice who has an
interview with
Nakamura well it's really terrible
waking up at 11:00 a.m. guys I mean it's
just getting all that sleep you know
it's just awful um but anyway I am with
Nakamura who also feels pretty lucky
today Naka you were simply dead busted
in this position how could you have
pulled off this miracle win yeah um I
mean first of all I think it was a
little bit silly to play the way that I
played I mean um actually I somehow I
felt like even though we've only played
two rounds it was kind of time that I
had to try and do something crazy um
this early with two two solid draws
already so what happens sometimes I me
when people start with plus two or plus
three I mean okay Wesley's probably
going to draw this game but still like I
I don't know he drew it already that's
already but it's just kind of I felt
like I had to go crazy and create
something which was completely the wrong
attitude um and yeah I got in a lot of
trouble but it was never like a one move
win so um I think Fabiano had a couple
ways to win he probably should have
played this G4 move um when I when we
after we played H4 H5 and then I think
he was probably winning on the spot but
um once once he pushes Pawn to C6 and
then C7 I I didn't see a clear win I
mean probably can just move his pieces
back and play the three pieces against
the two Rooks and win but already he was
down to maybe 30 seconds so uh I mean
it's a little bit hard to play like that
practically speaking and and then yeah I
just kept kept surviving and eventually
uh I mean he got too low he made a
couple of really bad moves and then it
was uh too late for him it really is
mystifying how you were able to get out
of it but it's it's definitely your
style do you feel like the faster time
control you kind of just find certain
weird geometrics that other people don't
spot as easily well I mean it's was kind
of only moves I mean so uh when there
only moves on the board it's uh I think
natur were trained to find them I mean
it's uh that's just the way modern day
chess is I think when you use computers
so much unless you're like just losing
the position you're always expecting
there to be some kind of resource if you
look hard enough so um yeah I just just
kept trying to find moves that didn't
lose right away and uh and it it seemed
to work I mean Fabiano couldn't couldn't
quite find The Knockout blow and uh got
you know kept surviving he got to a long
time and then then I just took over
three rounds done definitely a a Mis
death in this one how are you feeling
about today now that the games are over
uh I feel good um I mean to be on plus
one's obviously fantastic uh I guess I'm
like one point out of the lead which is
which is always good but uh I'll have to
play better tomorrow and the following
day uh to stay in contention I think all
right well good luck with the rest of
your games thank you he car Nakamura you
can see why he was the champion of Paris
last year it's not easy to beat this guy
even when he's in the grave he's still
frighting and punching back and finding
those only moves
thank you marce and well done hikaro
what a say what a well yes what to say
what to say you know really the only
thing we can say is Fabiano yeah go for
a
run get how does that affect our
standings well yeah let's check them out
so uh let's have a look so of course
still in the lead tied with Magnus it's
wle so and Magnus Carlson on Five
Points not far behind not far behind
vesselin toov and hikaro nakamuro four
points and uh three players on 50% Maxim
Mas and shakar mamaro and alexand gik
right Sergey kakan with two out of a
potential six ettien on the scoreboard
but there's the Shocker oh my
gosh oh Maurice's Choice yes oh and
Alejandro's too by
we have the Spanish commentary going
[Music]
uh and we're go to Paris yes we'll go to
Paris well for more interviews with
Maurice
Ashley yes and we're with shock that is
mamadov who had a win this round after a
bad round last time you must have felt
really bitter losing that game to Magnus
when you had a good position of course
it was big mistake against Magnus uh it
was look so okay normal position maybe
okay I I think I can play for wi
something to take PA E7 okay it was very
bad but okay I just miss his move Bishop
F3 when his position equal I mean it's
normal but okay now next game uh against
Sergey I had some problems I mean I
think it's it was little bit bad
position for me but uh Serge played bad
in the games and I won your first time
on the grand chest tour I talked with
you yesterday about being here how does
it feel now that you're actually playing
the games uh of course this very
interesting tournaments top players and
every game is Fighting Chess is very
nice I like it and this also rapid games
and bit also I like too much and I'm
very happy to be here and it's just
three games is finished hope to play
next six games good you feel you've
cleaned out uh any of the nervous
nervousness from the first day is done
and it's time to play the chess we've
seen you've been playing which has been
amazing chess over the last few months
of course not nervous because it's uh I
play against his chess players too many
times in other tournaments of course I
play him first time in this tournament
Grand Tour uh this is very interesting
to play good I mean it is very strong
tournament but I have no nervous
everything is okay everything in control
just play chess all right well we look
forward to seeing you just play chess in
the rest of the games yes
Shakir mad jirov uh playing chess
playing well playing solid and he said
not nervous so expect him to be a
Powerhouse in the rest of the game
absolutely certainly no nerves yeah well
the way he's been playing he shouldn't
be he should been so impressive but what
a way to start uh the grand chest tour
uh just uh very very very eventful three
rounds Christian your take on these
rounds final thoughts please incredible
day guys a great beginning to the Grand
chest tour Magnus Carson has found his
old self his own a role uh Wesley so
unex for me unexpectedly after his
disaster in Norway he's doing really
really well this tournament seems to be
transforming into a two horse race uh
but the Shocker was Fabiano caruana zero
out of three he needs to come back mmed
arov on the other side he's doing well
he only lost to Magnus Carlson he made a
draw and now bounc back with a nice win
over karakin so I'm expecting Fighting
Chess over the next two days in Paris
yes thank you for sure
yes so Maurice what are your final
thoughts well certainly this day has
been absolutely entertaining here in
Paris we had the heat we all been
sweating like crazy but now on the chess
board the players have had to sweat and
it's just simply been a Topsy Turvy
crazy
day yeah typical rapid chest this is why
we we love the stem control well many
blunders not funny for everybody but uh
well very pleasant for spectators to see
some ups and downs in the games so
indeed many many surprises many blunders
many many upsets okay especially seeing
Fabiano karona with zero out of three
out of these three positions is just
completely unbelievable but this is
rapid chess and uh well there are 27
games here so he has time to be back and
then
uh some some lucky players some and some
unlucky players so probably that
probably it will change yeah we'll see
most definitely one thing we can say is
we're going to see more mistakes
happening for sure and more exciting
games so we look forward to seeing the
action on day two tomorrow as these
players go at it here in Paris thank you
Maurice so what a day what a day day but
we'll say our goodbyes we hope you'll
join us tomorrow for more Thrills and
Spills from the grand chest tour
2017 see you tomorrow for day
[Music]
two